e
[Musique]
ça gêne pas le banat niel moi c'est pour
la personne qui est derrière un bon on
est prêt un sergio
[Musique]
mystère
pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui a jeté de l'eau j'aime pas
balancer mais je crois avoir vu méline
dans le barrage à malines mailing il
aussi c'est toi tu as jeté de l'eau
méline nom bien alors chers amis chers
ennemis bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle l'émission qui parle
avec nous ce soir
thierry lhermitte
messieurs le boulot victoria abril
jboss
lampach
[Applaudissements]
l'herbe
la fosse clone de galles
[Applaudissements]
crédit
hommage à felip cordier
laurent baffie qu'est ce qui s'est passé
remarque c'est bien de rentrer doucement
comme ça c'est pas mal aussi
savatier rit ça va très bien j'ai une
bonne nouvelle tuerie j'aimerais que tu
lis mouna ayoub suite à mon engagement
envers vous et monsieur laurent baffie
il ya une faute attendant laurent oui
j'ai le plaisir de vous faire parvenir
ma donation de dix mille euros
sympa pour votre honorable action pour
la fondation clowns sans frontières il
ya les premiers à l'appel chèque et
regarde l'adresse de klaus aux
frontières qui défilent ouais bien en
tous les cas merci mena youba alors
l'avant que reporters sans frontières
s'est bien passé on fait la liste de
toutes nos actions de charité comme ça
voilà le costume sardou est toujours là
c'est un peu vexant pour michel sardou
franchement si quelqu'un pouvait
l'acheter honnêtement ça serait mieux
parce que la prisonniers politiques
peut-être ça ferait monter les prix non
parce que ce costume il est quand même
là depuis deux mois et à la rentrée il
va revenir mais imaginez qu'il allait
leur acheter moins mais on attend de ses
nouvelles
j'ai pas michel sardou si tu nous
entends en plus si tu la taille michel
satan mer
bien alors tu sais le rock monde en
parle va exister au québec
oui tu m'as dit cela voilà ça va
s'appeler tout on en parle et le garçon
qui va le présenter s'appelle guy a
lepage
parce que là bas ils ont un truc entre
le prénom et le nom du ca
d'accord on bien c'est incroyable je
crois bien voici guy a lepage
[Musique]
voilà oui ça va bien parce qu'il fallait
quand même à nos amis téléspectateurs
c'est que guy a lepage a mis une chemise
agnès b bien sûr tout vous êtes
l'inventeur de un gars une fille
oui comme tellement de succès par chez
nous ouais j'essaie de m'adapter laurent
c'est normal qu'est ce qui dit non mais
c'est un marché non de quoi faire à la
place alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont diffusé les mêmes quoi ils font
des best of the best of the best off
parce que on pense pas qu'on trouvera
mieux mais chez nous on fait la même
chose
wariner l'an passé ont fait débat bravo
merci donc vous allez présenter tout le
monde en parle au québec
alors ce que ce que je vous propose
c'est de vous mettre là quand notre
invité suivant va arriver à côté il y
aura qui pour me remplacer moi mon
équivalent assez difficile à trouver à
des personnes non parce que ouais j'ai
vu offrir le double oui bien sûr ouais
le tri non mais il n'y a pas
d'équivalent chez nous parce que chez
nous un vanard c'est un baveux un baveux
bellevue et nous en avons eu peur nous
un avocat chez nous c'est compliqué les
cultures et un sniper chez nous c'est un
poisson comme vous il y en a pas
vraiment avec un look un peu me puchot
me pervers ça existe pas envie de jouer
tôt
traité de paix si votre père vers 5
secondes donc tu prends des notes
oui et à la rentrée tu t'habilles en
noir voilà c'est promis le noir pour la
premier league
tu sais
hier
m
et puis
samedi
et maintenant
[Musique]
si non que tu ailles chaudhry le peut
s'imaginer même le blond daily what she
said ermite
[Musique]
c
bonsoir merci à de cet accueil faut le
rester assis merci beaucoup d'être nom
n'a pas été accueilli comme ça sinon
talent pour moi ce total nous allons un
peu marre c'est la fin c'est possible on
s'est beaucoup ont tapé dix ans c'est
clair que ça c'est l'avant dernière
parce que l'avant avant dernière c'est
une émission comme une autre la dernière
c'est la dernière mais l'avant rien
d'ailleurs c'est mal tombé dernière
thierry c'est une corvée pour vous de
faire de la promo télé comme ça non une
corvée je n'irai pas jusque là mais
c'est pas mon métier moment et ce n'est
pas les pas d'aller vendre ma salade ses
détracteurs de faire au mieux pour
interpréter ce qu'on me demande bon donc
bas et quelquefois ccc ouais c'est plus
dur ouais tu vois ce que je veux dire ça
c'est fait vous êtes obligés par contrat
le faire non non vous le faites vraiment
pour aider le film on le fait oui quand
quand on aime le film et quand
oui hein alors j'ai vu le film gerry le
film s'appelle qui perd gagne de laurent
bénégui avec elsa zylberstein maurice
bénichou et vous évidemment alors cesser
d'arrêter je crois quand l'animateur a
pas vu le film vous vous le sentez à
vous le sentez à quoi ou vague des
questions racontez-nous thierry
lhermitte cette intrigue passionnante
dakar elle avoue du film
moi je les ai vus et zylberstein il est
super sexy dans le film a vraiment j'ai
jamais vu comme ça
oh la la si c'est vous qui lui fait de
cet effet non c'est bien possible
elle est belle à quoi la très belle et
même un peu dans match d'aujourd'hui
question très classe ce qui fait dire à
nos amis que les spectateurs c'est que
le film commence par une scène de baise
à billets ce qui est pas bon pas bon du
tout quand vous faites ça bah c'est pas
le boulot
elle connaît le métier de son mari alors
on prend bientôt que les asiles bertone
cette si belle fille après pour le un
poil rappelons le est capitaine les
renseignements généraux et directrice de
la brigade des jeux et lui c'est à dire
vous vous êtes un requin des tapis verts
alors la fliquer le tricheur vivent une
liaison secrète en fait depuis plusieurs
années et c'est là qu'un obscur
professeur de mathématiques gagne deux
fois de suite au loto voilà alors le le
log line du film ça veut dire quoi
c'est la phrase qui écrivent sur la
fiche d'accord le lenglen du film donc
c'est ce film ne vous dit pas comment
gagner au loto il vous dit comment
gagner deux fois au loto
puisque ce prof de maths a développé une
théorie soit disant pour gagner
infailliblement au loto alors ce type là
est il un escroc ou un génie
en tous les cas il vient une star parce
qu'il est pris en main par un
publicitaire absolument insensé et là
s'il ya une façon de gagner au loto
ça veut dire que c'est plus la peine de
jouer donc le chiffre d'affaires de la
française des jeux s'effondre l'état
croupier vacille on dit pas l'état
croupion non l'état croupier est la
fille d 'argent essais libres à
silverstone trouve rien de mieux que de
confier l'anc est à son amant le
le tricheur le requin des tapis verts il
ya que lui qui puisse se débrouiller
l'histoire mal raconté normal on
absolument et donc c'était ces
escroqueries au loto et bomba forcément
bien sûr qui est une escroquerie bien
sûr qu'ils aient pas de martingale pour
gagner deux fois de suite
ouais donc payant heureux et le mec a
vraiment gagné deux fois de suite donc
il ya escroquerie et ckoi l'escroquerie
moi c'est ça qui m'a fait tourner les
passes réussies spence qui a déjà vu un
film retour de martingale non avec
exactitude alors ça normalement le
couple au montage mais là je le couple
c'est l'ami jean lasseille de la nive
oui c'est génial y un vrai sénart en
plus il ya un vrai suspense et c'est
très intéressant lorsque vous allez
faire parce qu'il faut bien que les gens
voient à quoi ça ressemble vous allez
regarder votre caméra et vous allez dire
magnéto slaoui magnéto serge comme ça
qu'il faut faire
fait unique dans l'histoire du lotto a
même parieur a trouvé la combinaison
gagnante deux fois de suite ce qui porte
le montant de ses gains à plus de 11
d'euros je suis parvenu à des monstres
il savait que l'on pouvait donc tu es le
hasard
ça fait rêver la terre entière rêver
bien des fois c'est au loto reste
impossible
on va le conseil
c'est jacques loriot et une dizaine
d'années il a fait sauter toutes les
tables de blackjack multiplient contre
coeur tout ça c'est un talent à l'état
pur les derniers hits souviennent tous
les permanences pourquoi vous nous
parler de ce type qui fait équipe avec
nous sera favorable
sûrement pas envie de passer du côté des
flics
cet ami
l'écran la vie impossible
compliqué de vous laisser rentrer vous
est interdit dans les pas faire ça
devrait jamais couché avec un flic
servait toujours un coup franc la vie
agréable un petit qu un joueur compulsif
abonnés allawi doit choisir ce type n'a
pas pu tricher
le système de la française des jeux
était un violeur dès que j'en ai la
gagner comme une fois deux fois de suite
et c'est impossible
absolument donc hélas pas forcément
quelque chose que tu nous échapper pour
comprendre que tu travailles au beau
temps et crache le morceau voilà il a
été ce qu'achète inculpation dans les
récidives
on va visiter de gagner trois fois de
suite le taux est de 1 sur 2 mille
milliards de milliards d'ici est un
génie c'est un génie médiation puis s'en
fout plein les poches depuis le début de
cette histoire
ça tourne mal
tout l'argent plein vol
c'est aussi un trek iv regagne de
l'embellie
avec elsa zylberstein et
et notre invité ce soir
sortie le 23 juin voilà alors vous avez
accepté le film parce que laurent
bénégui d'abord avait fait au petit
marguery absolument qu est un film assez
sympa déjà et puis bon le scénar plein
de plein d'humour plein de suspense
ouais pileux ce truc là c'est ça qui m'a
fait tourner les pages - vraiment
comment est-ce qu'un mec peut tricher
pour gars en gagnant deux fois de suite
au loto il n'y a pas de complicité dans
les tic n est pas faux tickets il n'y a
pas de complicité à la française des
jeux
le tirage voilà c'est pas mal c'est pour
de vrai ça peut exister alors votre
personnage thierry lhermitte c'est à la
fois génie un loser c'est un génie parce
qu'il est hyper mesic
il a une mémoire incroyable introduit
noir voilà une super mémoire il se
souvient de tours tout l'éclairage
c'était très utile pour les pour les
cartes dans les casinos parce
qu'évidemment il se souvient de toutes
les cartes ont été distribuées son côté
génial et son côté loser c'est qu'il est
accroché au jeu mais que c'est une
maladie hypermnésie parce que ça a l'air
marrant de se souvenir de tours en
l'occurrence c'est probablement
invivable je pense que ça existe
complètement 7-5 pour tous est pourri le
cerveau on sature un petit peu le voilà
certaines et femmes certaines vannes
québécoise donc c'est bien sûr mais ma
n'en connaissent pas pourrir par le
passé pas la même culture 1
et donc l'hyper brésil conduit à avoir
des rapports très calculée avec les
autres un grand désavantage qu'elle le
calme souligne un moment elsa parce
qu'on va se séparer un moment dans
l'histoire et elle me dit le problème
c'est que moi dans quelques temps ton
visage va s'est passé je penserai à
autre chose et c'est alors que toi ça va
durer longtemps voilà un gros
désavantage quand même c'est terrible
une histoire d'amour vous avez une bonne
mémoire vous à l'époque du lycée pasteur
à neuilly il était quelle boulevard ce
lycée pasteur
ackermann bravo après le lycée après le
lycée vous jouez dans une boîte qui
s'appelle aux poteaux c'était l'adresse
c'était c'était rue de la banque à
prendre des photos non non non
le un poste au milieu de la scène un
essai gt le titre wpt est juste au
milieu bravo le titre de cette pièce que
vous jouiez au poteau non georges pas
ici bien après ma tête est malade deux
comédiens vous rejoignent pour aménager
le second splendide rue des lombards il
ya une fille un garçon il y avait jose
balasko et bruno à nos halls alors
qu'elle mais moi quand même là dessus
comme ça me chante rien fait depuis
alors 78 vous rencontrer hélène ex
mannequin c'est le coup de foudre
adresse du restaurant vous l'avez
rencontré la rue rue saint denis
bravo 80 vous flashez sur adjani dans
clara elle est chic type nom du
personnage a effacé s'est effacée avec
des enfants il en violence et plus
magnifique mais j'ai appris comment il
s'appelait bertrand bertrand avant les
ripoux vous tournez until september nom
de la majeure mgm 86e sont vos débuts de
producteurs et d'acteurs dans nuit
d'ivresse long du réalisateur mais c'est
dur pour le mec mais je sais faut dire
que le meneur bo n'a bernard bernard
assez horrible horrible c'est ce que
excuse-moi bernard gimbernat et voilà
t'imagines avec ces horribles sénat jean
bernard là comme il est mal sa famille
dit il parle ça le showbiz mais là les
gens sont édifiés au complet tiens je
couperai pas au montage à je peux vous
dire tout de suite je crois que s'ouvrir
les veines
bon je vais vous le dire les charitables
bernard noël mamère bernard noël
alors
série b remis ce prix obtenu par un
indien dans la ville en 1995 dans la
catégorie meilleur producteur
oui oui c'était le prix de meilleur prix
georges bourde de beauregard à voir le
titre du remake us du père noël est une
ordure mix note bravo n'ont ni
réalisateur oublier n'aura nora ephron
sommes bien sûr à vos plats sur tt ou
dans les 26 et 27
ben c'est pas mal c'est une bonne
mémoire quand même s'effectuer de ses
biens
merci alors on entend presque mais
qu'ils aient des bronzés vos
retrouvailles après 20 ans tournage en
mai 2005
c'est ça qu'est ce qui me fait le plus
plaisir quand vous retrouver entre vous
l'idée de re dire des conneries tout va
pendant toute la journée pendant tant
qu'on écrit de ouais c'est ça qu'est ce
qui nous fait pas rire c'est christian
clavier il ne peut pas rire j'écris sans
clavier qui vont de pair
qu'ils soient clavier un mec super drôle
nous fait pas rire ces questions clavier
ouais sans doute là il me prend de court
qu'est ce qui me fait pareil sécrétion
de lie to me fait rire c'est que son
travail tout me fait rire je suis grand
cliente présente la vie qu'est ce qui
vous rend pas jaloux sujet à rio
qu'est-ce qui ment pas jaloux je sais je
ne sais pas sa coiffure peut-être qu'est
ce qui vous séduit le plus chez josiane
balasko
qu'est ce qui me séduit le plus le sco
c'est son rire oui oui son humour son
rire son intelligence sa joie de vivre
voilà bien qu'est ce qui manque à michel
blanc pour vous séduire
si l'artiste en a plein le cul tu dis
j'aurais peut-être fait pas de se voir
plus souvent
voilà ça y est l'hypocrisie au bout d'un
moment ça revient ça devient bon alors
ya eu notre promo ce que fait double
promo ce soit vous savez ça quand même
un voilier au caire est double effet
kiss cool l'autre promo on en parlera à
la semaine prochaine plus longuement
avec patrick timsit et lorànt deutsch
c'est l'américain où vous jouez le rôle
d'un avocat froid et cynique qui est de
lorànt deutsch à être américain à
l'obtenir nationalité américaine
exactement 1
c'est une idée de cette idée de fou de a
germé dans l'idée de passer dans la tête
de patrick timsit lorànt deutsch est un
mec qui paie qui pense qu'il a le jeune
américain et caustique il est américain
comme les gens qui seront transsexuels
qui me pensent qu'ils sont nés dans le
mauvais côté quelque sorte absolument
mais voilà donc ils sont qui est
américain et voilà je suis l'avocat qui
prend le pari de les obtenir la
nationalité alors on va regarder le
teaser voulait recommencer je suis
désolé c'est un petit peu mais bon vous
avez regardé votre caméra et vous allez
dire encore une fois magnéto serge serge
magnéto non non c'est cela
ils ont occupé qu'à school rock et
magnéto serge bonjour je m'appelle
francis charges du lotissement des
merlettes et je suis américain non
monsieur but français alors je n'ai rien
faut se rendre à l'évidence je suis
américain français oui bah non ça suffit
les mérites monsieur farges c'est pas
trois types à cheval dans une vallée
attaqué par des sous non monsieur charge
le coût est finie on this ce que
j'entende ne me fait pas plaisir du tout
on va faire des efforts en permanence et
au niveau langue au niveau langue
il a les bases mais pas les bonnes ces
phoques tous les trois gros sacs chitray
d'étiquettes en place ce qui veut dire
qu'elle tournait dans le cul
[Musique]
c'est dans die hard 3
oui
[Musique]
si l'américain en entendant la semaine
prochaine donc avec patrick timsit et
lorànt deutsch
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir beaucoup
changé depuis vos débuts avec le
splendide
non mais toi non plus tu n'as pas changé
mais c'est toi qui va répondre aux
questions à faire une interview
changement
[Musique]
thierry lhermitte voulait dire que la
dernière fois je suis venu ici j'ai fait
une interview mensonge
oui et alors tu sais après s'est repris
quelques fois dans les best of mais sans
dire que ces interviews mensonge est ok
alors il ya du mae demande est ce que me
ton vrai nom ces tensions s'étaient
également
donc je voudrais rectifier parce qu'il
ya des gens qui me casse les couilles à
longueur dames du genre je crois qu'on
est cousin je m'appelle paient en fait
tueur ni ton nom de tales alors à ce que
j'avais dit moi c'est comme si je
m'appelais tél je n'aurais pas pris
lhermitte comme pseudo pareil tu vois
voilà bien ce qui a changé dans la
couleur de vos yeux monsieur tu ailles
sont devenus plus de jeunes séparation
c'est ça oui c'est vrai si si le sens
les nouvelles oeuvres aux fins plus
profond c'est ça le gonfle dans votre
coiffure et éclat clairsemé un peu plus
clair sommet dans le regard des filles
de 20 ans ah oui oui vous adore ce qui a
changé dans votre façon de faire l'amour
thierry l'expérience à c'est
c'est vrai hein c'est vrai rien c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce qui a changé dans vos
peurs thierry lhermitte des trucs qui me
faisait pas peur avant et puis
maintenant je suis parti en bateau
pendant un an ça me faisait pas peur est
maintenant l'idée la mer me fait peur
alors j'avais pas peur du tout c'est
vrai que vous allez faire un tour du
monde avec hélène d'ailleurs et votre
couple a résisté à ce tour du moulin ont
fait le test du tour du monde en bateau
qu'est ce qui a changé dans l'émission
vous êtes invités tout abbaye pue ça
déforme ce désespoir mais qu'est ce qui
a changé tu sais quoi qui se passait qui
avait pas avant il n'y avait pas les
applaudissements et les hurlements tout
le temps
et je parle d'un temps que les moins de
vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître
j'ai connu aussi et qu'est ce qui n'a
pas changé
finalement depuis vos débuts avec le
splendide thierry lhermitte folle envie
de dire des conneries et le web avec des
codes rigides pas voilà c'est pas trop y
croire
ouais guy a est-ce que je crois qu'il
est assez habile
ah oui c'est à cause ardisson qui
s'appelle guy méresse sur un match un
peu en direct dit est ce que tu aurais
une question à poser à thierry lhermitte
oui
et bien pose là mais non qu'est ce que
vous préférez le théâtre le cinéma ou
16e n'est pas terminée
qu'est ce qui se passe je conseillerais
aux gens qui n'ont pas assez d'argent
pour voir les deux films il est juste de
quoi un ticket à christian pourri c'est
pas ben peut-être que sinon il ya un
pouvoir qui perd gagne il achète le
ticket il gagne au loto ils auront
largement de quoi valoir le bonne
réponse
longtemps
[Musique]
il
mais
si michel mouillot
[Musique]
c'est
gimont swarm soir connaissent et thierry
lhermitte oui et guy a lepage
il a présenté tout le monde en parle au
québec a commencé tout le monde en parle
au québec n'ont pas leur arriver à tout
moment bien alors michel mouillot vous
êtes un ex ami de françois léotard donc
ex membres de son parti le parti
républicain le fameux prx maire de
cannes ex vice président du conseil
régional de paca et vous avez été
condamné en 1995 dans la sphère botton à
18 mois de prison avec sursis pour
emplois fictifs en 1996 de l'incarcérer
quinze mois après avoir été mis en
examen pour deux affaires de pots-de-vin
versés par des casinos cannois le
carlton et le noga hilton le 9 juin
dernier j'ai été condamné à trois ans de
prison ferme et 50 mille euros d'amendé
pour corruption dans la sphère
immobilière du relais de la reine sur la
croisette voilà et d'ici la fin de
l'année
michel mouillot vous retournerez devant
les tribunaux pour la faire carlton pour
laquelle j'ai déjà fait 15 mois de
détention provisoire
bientôt 20 ans
sérieux
bien j'avais la carte vous êtes libéré
de prison c'est dans mon jeu et c'est
dans ce contexte michel mouillot que
vous publié chez michel lafon tous
mouillés faut dire que le titre est
assez rigolo tout à se mouiller ou vous
dites lever le voile sur les hypocrisies
du système de financement des partis
car vous dit en fait que les sommes
détournées n'était pas du tout pour
votre enrichissement personnel mais
était destiné aux personnes n'ont pas
été prouvées voilà c'était destiné au
financement du parti de françois léotard
ça c'est clair voilà c'est un peu dans
le cas de d'emmanuelli une certaine
époque où d'alain juppé plus récemment
avec un traitement différent ouais avec
un traitement largement différent oui
c'est vrai et d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il
faut un petit peu en parler c'est ma
maison était plus sourcilleux avec toi
qu'avec et magnolia et il est bien sûr
ceux issus mais ils ont aussi des rires
mieux qu au siom tu veux plus sympa avec
toute une série de gens qui sont
peut-être un petit peu plus par exemple
que toi ouais et c'est pour ça que ce
bouquin existe un petit peu parce que
j'ai un peu marre de prendre des tas de
deux casseroles sur les autres qui vous
dit michel mouillot c'est que malgré la
loi de 1990 en fait rien n'a changé rien
strictement rien je 2000 2001 les partis
reçoivent chaque année en fonction du
nombre de députés
une somme de la part de l'état pour
financer leurs activités
aucun candidat sur le terrain qui se
présentent à n'importe quelle élection
avec l'étiquette de son parti du
changement
ouais ou va-t-il les trouver comment les
trouve-t-il il faut caractériques l'état
- les trouver l'état donne chaque année
aux partis politiques 150 millions
d'euros ya ce qui va ou ce pognon reste
simplement à une fois appuyé la shoah où
on fait les beaux ont fait les grands
meetings ont fait des rampes c'est ça où
on traite les leaders aux lego on l'est
on les gaz un petit peu on en paye tous
les frais de déplacement et le type
hambach qui se présente au conseil
général conseil régional au à la
députation et bien ce type là il se
débrouille ouais je suis correct ça veut
dire que depuis qu' à cette dotation de
150 millions d'euros
il ya ça en plus de ce qu'ils avaient
avant c'est dire qu'avant n'y avait rien
à voir mais d'accepter un resto dans la
démence
il ya toujours la démerde non seulement
il règle est d'accord il ya toujours des
trucs qui sont confrontés à des
problèmes de financement à l'échelle
mios et je suis coupable mais finalement
tout le monde est coupable et je suis
tout le monde est coupable bien grand
nombre de coupables est ce qu'ils savent
que ça se passe ce qu'ils ne disent rien
et qui ne font rien d'ailleurs qui
souhaite bien à l'abri de ceux qui
prennent des risques
tout le monde le sait personne n'a envie
de changer la loi
personne n'a envie que les choses
changent et moi je dis non ça danse
libre avant avec des nains des grottes
un peu constituante sûrs de trois types
que j'ai bien aimé le qui m'ont trahi
généreusement gentiment ça existe des
gens qui trahissent en politique vous le
savez très bien les amis n'existe pas
mais les traites existe trois avoue une
sale ambiance dans le groupe je trouve
mais n'entend pas se regarder faut pas
casser l'ambiance on devait quand même
pas prendre les gens pour des cons coin
bien alors on va reprendre les choses 2
0 déjà
et oui c'est un prêt dont le match mais
pas commencer vous êtes né en 1943 à
nice et repasse fils d'horticulteurs
étude on peut le dire sans être vexant
son relief n'aura aucune aucun 40e
carole y est encore là pote exito kulm
croyais que relief et féminin vous êtes
vous savez lire ni écrire des critiques
ont commencé les chats courte formation
aux usa oui largement courte largement
militaire disneyland koala chicago à mon
avis pour apprendre son boulot artiste
donc sauvage finissez ouais vous
finissez chez pernod ricard a pris 68
je débute chez pernod ricard et pernod
en débats sont hélas chez pernod ricard
de chef de produit vous passez
finalement et je te dis que tu as marqué
ta directeur du marshal cohen et ou
alors vous savez qu'à l'époque chez
pernod ricard michel boyon vos surnommé
le ventilateur pascal brassier beaucoup
d'herbe c'est un peu facile peut-être
qu'à deux balles ce nom mais ce tir
normal qu'on trouvait qu'on sur les
plateaux de télévision la médiévale qui
brasse un peu prochaine c'est vrai mais
c'est pas fait pas de salle michel ici
ce qui est bien c'est que superficiel
c'est vrai mais c'est pas vrai non c'est
pas vrai du tout et encore mais c'est un
truc inventé par vos copains alors en
mille
23 vous rencontrer françois léotard et
vous devenez ami
léotard me plaît bien et donc il me
demande d'assurer sa communication et
pas celle du parti puis finalement on me
demande de travailler un petit peu pour
les machins les trucs des affiches et je
rencontre un type absolument éblouissant
jean pierre raffin oui la raffarin était
chargé en fait à l'époque et je la fais
non non non présence pas seulement met
pas son corps séparé chargé il était
chez bernard krief consultants et il
travaillait avec les au tard à la
communication
alors là vous n'êtes pas tendre avec
jean pierre raffarin plus je tiens vous
voulez vous que je sois tendre avec des
gens qui n'ont jamais été l'amour mais
ça ça te passera un petit peu car sinon
voila je dis la vérité bien alors vous
dit en parlant de jean pierre raffarin
qu'il est dévoré par l'ambition générale
alors tu généralité déjà fini pour nous
alors qu'un petit mec est bien marché
c'est ce paresseux
oui largement paresseux à l'époque il
était peut-être qui s'est foutu au
travail du négatif et calculateur jeu il
a des larges responsabilités à ne sais
pas si ses responsabilités du sens donné
à retirer lorsqu'il le faut mais en tout
cas à l'époque ils étaient empêchés
largement les gens de travailler quand
quelque chose marche et voilà donc
aujourd'hui évidemment vous étonnez pas
qu'il lève pas le petit doigt pour vous
sortir de notre camp n'a jamais levé de
toute façon il n'aurait jamais levé
d'accord à vous êtes sans effusion il a
eu avec elle était quand avec la classe
politique si vous avez des illusions au
fait m un assez clair bien et vous
raconter également la jalousie de alain
madelin pour les auteurs vous dit en
fait il était message je savais que ça
reçoit qu'ils étaient les meilleurs
alistair mais sérieusement à me citer
tout le morro non pas du tout mais vous
le pensiez à l'époque je sais oui c'est
lorsque notre nous avons fait une
rencontre avec sept heures raconte est
la même à bouquin on a une réunion
madelin jaloux de la communication de
léotard du succès de vo tard époque
madelin invite sorte task force un peu
un peu tout le monde et il me demande de
venir est en charge de la communication
des odeurs vidant peut-être que lui va
nous amener quelque chose et puis il
invite un type qu'on voit arriver
complètement défait les territoires
personne ne savait qui sait
thierry ardisson et ils nous annoncent
avant qu'il arrive j'ai un peut-être en
nouveaux conseillers dans communication
que j'ai envie de vous préciser qu'il
avait rendez vous et vous avez rencontré
certainement dans une soirée et vous
avez dit entre deux énervés
bien sûr que je viens et le voilà arrivé
au risque le matin à 8h30 d'été
complètement et les ajouter 10 a ajouté
qu'après cette région je voulais j'avais
lu non je suis non j'ajoute que vous
vous demandiez vraiment ce que vous
veniez vert au milieu de toute cette
bande de cancres et que vous êtes
qu'assez rapidement en disant tiens
voilà oui vous vous êtes resté
malheureusement réduite à 2 2 trucs vous
arrivez partir j'étais allé vous vous
étiez un homme alors en entrant en
politique vous découvrez les magouilles
financières vous découvrez la trahison
déjà à commencer par les auteurs lui les
ministres de la culture en 86 il nous
avait promis un secrétariat d'état
et vous vous retrouvez chargé de mission
c'est quoi rien de tout de rien pas du
café
enfin pas des cafés bars comme rafa
n'est qu'un nom j'étais en charge de
l'intérieur et un peu des grands travaux
voilà et ensuite michel mouillot vous
partez à espace 3 qui était la régie de
france 3 est est ce que c'est un moyen
détourné du pognon pour le non pas du
tout alors là strictement pas et
d'ailleurs ils ont tous cherché mais là
non franchement pas non non non moi je
fais le bon sauf c'est que ça marche
vachement il a je crois que ça marche
pas à la même époque donc léotard vous
incite à prendre une mairie sur la côte
d'azur et vous choisissez kahn est bien
mal vous en a pris parce que la mairesse
de cannes à l'époque était anne marie
dupuis qui est une amie intime des
chirac
avait pas de pot là je dirais même que
celle qu'on le dit la personne qui a mis
le pied à l'étrier en politique à
jacques cher mais alors un truc fabuleux
que vous ne savez pas on m'investit on
me dit présente toi
t'inquiète pas on me promet
l'investiture et quinze jours avant
qu'est ce qu'on fait mon pote les eaux
il a finalement arrivée puis ça c'est de
l'amitié donc valise en carton et je
gagne quoi alors une valise c'est bien
la voix nous a laissé la hat a prévu une
petite valise qu'on en suisse pictet cie
pour la pâte sur cannes
il est gonflé tu veux qu'on te raconte m
c'est bon
laurent laurent s'est fait
merveilleusement ce genre de conneries à
de mal cela dit on sait pas de balancer
du chiffon c'est du papier on voit cela
dit il faut le faire à chaque type
politique parce que je suis persuadé
qu'il ya dans la loge voilà alors ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'anne marie dupuis
donc c'est la copine des chirac vraiment
amis intimes
damien billets et à un moment il ya des
tracts qui sortent à cannes avec marc et
qu'elle et alcoolo et inverti où il rend
évidemment vous accuse le diplôme mieux
but le seul chaînon de la bande c'est
moi un message étiquettes sans rien on
vous accuse
on m'accuse alors que c'est d'être un
ouais enfin là dessus ils ont laissé
tomber parce que c'est on a appris
depuis que c'était une manip et c est là
le rpr décide de vous tuer mais
seulement voilà oui ça fait un petit
moment qu'ils avaient envie se
débarrasser de mort il envoie deux mecs
qui leur avait fait physiquement c'est
ce qui va compter c'est ce que vous
racontez votre beau gâchis sur wit que
le rp reims désigne deux bourreaux de
tueurs qui sont jacques toubon et jean
louis debré est la tête de la
machination contre vous sinon quand vous
êtes arrêté en 96 le commissaire vous
dit le rpr veut votre peau tout à fait
au lieu donc vous avez la preuve en fait
tout à fait mais je le dis
le commissaire se reconnaîtra remarquez
ils ont largement ils sont largement en
musique depuis et d'ici là léotard en
profite pour vous lâcher immédiatement
parce que lui en plus il ya des emmerdes
avec son mur après justin le mur le fond
d'eau
h à la piscine et où c'est beaucoup quoi
il veut pas en plus mais surtout il a
permis de construire je suis sûr que les
j'ai repris mon travail de marketing
la deuxième question c'est celle où moi
je me suis avoir un truc moi voilà quand
après la loi de 90 les tout le lot
l'ensemble des chefs politiques il faut
se dit bon ben on va continuer parce que
la pression peut pas faire autrement
surpasser d'argent que ses ventes
atteindront quand on fait des trucs il
donc contre la loi illégaux pour
récolter cet argent comment on pense
qu'on va jamais se faire gauler on sait
qu'on se fera pas voler ou comment ça
marche comment qu'est ce qu'on se dit
quand on dit voilà je vais taxer les
fausses factures du machin comme moi je
vais très franchement je vais vous dire
c'est que lorsque vous faites ce genre
de chose pour le p r nationale où nous
en faire non pas en fonction des 1 100
du pair ou penser que tout serait assuré
ne pas vous faire rigoler ça c'est clair
c'est ça voilà une heure mais juste hugo
almeida s'est pas mouillé ou nos marges
bien c'est tout le monde ensemble c'est
alors on se dise envie genre jamais
plainte bien sûr mais en demandant
d'appuyer vide et on pense qu'on est au
dessus des lois et s'est terminé alors
effectivement loi de 90 ans marc deux
jours avant vous des valises ce type
vous prenez ce dj bric pour le p r deux
jours après hop le trou
tant que c'est il ya une chose si vous
voulez qui est qui qui est gênante dans
tout ça c'est qu'en fait on ne change
pas en quatre jours les mentalités des
gens on ne change pas ce qu'ont fait les
traditionnellement on ne change pas
alors il faut arrêter de prendre les
gens pour des cons il faut arrêter de
penser que tout est réglé faut arrêter
de penser que les gens aujourd'hui qui
se présente aux élections sont aidés par
les parties il se démerde
et pour se démerder n'y a pas trente six
mille choses il ya soit on a une fortune
personnelle elle a pas beaucoup possible
à fond après certains il faut des
copains mais ils vont pas cracher au
bassinet très longtemps 1 surtout s'il
n'y a pas un kopeck à mettre dessus soit
il ya des entreprises qui pensent
qu'après ils vont travailler mais vous
ne savez pas la semaine vous donne vous
le prenez puis pour l'élection de cheikh
moins cher dit écoutez vous êtes élu
parfait alors qu'est ce qu'on fait 1
mais tout l'argent ne va pas au parti il
ya bien des miettes à ramasser mais ya
pas de miettes à ramasser
on vient tellement dépendre quand même
il ya tellement de sens tellement cher
tu vois des valises à l'extérieur ce
n'est pas tant dépend d'un petit comme
portrait du tout pas du tout mais non
alors ou alors un café comme on va faire
un mois je suis pas juge un jeu comme ça
comprendre pays mais non mais non mais
non c'est pas de politique
c'est du financement se réduisent non
malheureusement bien sûr le juge qui
s'occupe de votre cas qui n'est pas un
imbécile qui connaît tous sa part fait
pas forcément en tout cas qui pis c'est
tout ça qui sait tout ça à chips sont
pas 10 1 but sinon qui sait tout ça donc
il sait que tous les partis politiques
qui sait qu'il n'ya pas moyen de faire
autrement
en tout cas que ça que ça va pas changer
etc et qui s'acharne sur vous la filiale
a lâché -1 seulement il est simple
d'abord c'est parti à l'époque où il
fallait me faire tomber une fois que
vous êtes dans les tuyaux de gens les jo
terminés pour la seconde voilà terminé
et je peux vous dire que didier de bien
vous êtes est confirmé comme ils peuvent
pas avoir les autres eh ben ils vous
n'en faites un ptit coup supplémentaire
jeudi vous avez des gens qui ont financé
des partis qui se trouve avec deux ans
de prison avec sursis
moi ces trois ans ferme mais un petit
problème au comme ça pour des gens
raisonnables et puis un autre problème
savez le problème politique est
important mais il faut que vous sachiez
une chose c'est que lorsque
véritablement vous êtes dans le coup
quoi en vous donne moi j'ai fait 16 mois
cette affaire dont vous parlez date de
92 7 à 12 ans tu peux pas juger vous
avez 16 mois en boucle savait pas quand
vous sortez mais alors vous mais avec
toute la fine fleur de la chanson
française
vous avez déjà bout et vous avez 58000
innocent présence est bien connue et
dont vous ensuite vous sortez qui va
mettre un kopeck sur vous vous vous
allez m'engager comme personne ne vous
engage ses il faut quand même il faut
pas rêver vous vendez vous bien voilé
ceux de votre famille etc
ça fait ça fait jusqu'à 1 jusqu'à ya
deux ans je trouve du boulot
et là il ya une accélération une sorte
de de stratégie judiciaire qui se met en
place pour que tout le monde donc il
faut absolument après douze ans après
huit ans veut sortir tout de suite à ça
peut pas durer la kippa stains deux à
trois ans moi je passe à 8 10 ans mais
il faut se dépêcher là il ya eu il ya
une urgence alors
bien d'urgence savez très bien comment
fonctionnent les parcs et ils sont c'est
pas d'indépendance il est parquet
dépendent du ministère de la justice
mais certains justice bas dépend d'une
politique globale etc
alors moi je peux pas non plus remontés
justement michel mouillot vous tombez
sur le juge murciano qui est vraiment
oui peut très très dur un vraiment oui
enfin oui mais voilà vous n'avez pas
envie de vous fâcher tête avec lui tout
de suite dans la plus forte
il a sûrement ses bons côtés aussi
c'était parfait et alors vous vous
retrouvez en prison parce qu'ils
terrible c'est que quand votre mère
meurt là c'est horrible on me la prend
comme on vous apprend vous avez perdu
votre chien puis j'ai assisté à un
enterrement vote devant des juges ouais
je fais sortir pour la journée et là je
me retrouve avec une voiture devant une
voiture derrière comme comme quelqu'un
quand bien qui est qui et la tête le
cerveau de letea et donc j'insiste c'est
entièrement de ma mère et là vous vous
êtes le type qui est qu'il faut
surveiller mais à deux mètres de maître
avec les clichés sélectionnés et voilà
donc à partir de là il ne vous reste
plus michel bouillot que des souvenirs
j'ai quelque chose d'hilarion de mer à
cannes on vous appelez le maire tgv on
vous appeler le kiné dit de la croisette
mais ballack kennedy il ya
c'est lui qui distribue et les places à
toutes les sommités le festival de
cannes celui qui faisait des boeufs avec
clint eastwood absolument celui qui
rouler des pelles à chalon au nom stone
taton david j'ai un peu de mal non là le
truc de sharon stone il est vrai tout le
monde vous le dira ouais t'es un peu
pété était un peu parti ça si on me
présenta le maire vous perdiez lors d'un
périple et leur parti comme elle était
venue je pense qu'elle a dû rouler une
pelle au type après quoi c'est dû alors
aujourd'hui michel mouillot vous est
interdit de séjour à cannes aujourd'hui
depuis huit ans interdits de sortie du
territoire
huit ans vous être devenu consultant
pour des sociétés d'événementiel mais il
aura la fin du livre vous dites j'ai
tourné une page mais si le grand
architecte de l'univers le veut bien
le livre n'est pas terminée alors si la
seule allusion dans tout le bouquin à
votre appartenance à la franc-maçonnerie
pourtant vous aviez un titre de
vénérables pourquoi tout ça puisque ça
pourquoi vous oui pourquoi vous attendez
la fin du livre pour dire ça simplement
parce que je pense que ce que j'ai
appris dans cet ordre et c'est très
certainement très au dessus de tout ce
que j'ai pu apprendre en politique et
dans le monde profane et que je crois
que ça m'a laissé véritablement une
marque extrêmement solide que
j'emporterais très longtemps avec moi et
alex st-pierre et on comprend à présent
la truelle seriez michel ils nous ont
pas aidés vos copains franc mac quand ça
allait mal mais ils m'ont aidé et
comment il le redit m'ont tendu la main
mais que la main un type qui est
derrière les barreaux entre francis
heaulme et le
le lieutenant francis le belge ça aide
pas ils ont pas pu faire plus pour vous
non non non mais ils font ils seront pas
ils font pas ça un jeu font pas ça c'est
mon devoir c'est une preuve par là sinon
il croire que non mais j'ai une bonne
école de la vie oui voilà alors bientôt
vous allez peut-être entrer en prison
pour trois ans et ne s'est pas fait on a
été bons on est séparés ce qui fait que
le jel sans blague peu importe où vous
voulez qu'ils restent avec nous
non ce qu'on a fait ça c'est bon parce
qu'on va faire et savoir comment ça va
se passer on est derrière vous juste
avant
[Musique]
michel juste avant de rentrer en
toulouse allait embrasser qui bat
écouter tient dermit c'est pas tout à
fait le site de la maison c'est
certainement celle que celle qui
m'accompagnent dans ces difficultés le
gardien qui allez-vous avait la garde ce
dernier allait qu'ils allaient nous
placer votre la dernière nuit et ma
compagne irréprochable est-ce que vous
allez aller dans un bar gay juste vous
habituels ambiance dans même temps la
prison pour avoir une petite expérience
malheureuse de 16 mois je peux vous dire
que jusqu'à preuve du contraire j'ai pas
eu à subir les derniers outrages
ouais ouais mais je compte vous allez
exigé le carré viiip y'a pas je sais pas
s'il ya un carré viiip quelque part ou
pas j'étais entre francis heaulme et le
lieutenant koné sendrès ah oui c'est
vrai
non pas du tout ma cellule était là 1 je
veux dire que bonds a sévi à hippies
pour six hommes comprend certes comme
proximité en fait c'est bien pourtant
dormir l'année michel
il est musclé en taule faut bien faire
quelque chose en même temps je les perds
c'est écrit là quoi comme quart d'heure
des banques ayant bien sûr
[Musique]
voilà un michel mouillot merci je
précise que tout ce que vous dites dans
votre livre vous l'assumez évidemment
complètement
voilà ce qui est dit est dit vous avez
votre carte j'ai la carte la garde
d'ailleurs merci je t'en prie aime
échanger une fois que le père de films
paix fait un petit cadeau c'est sa balle
et encore merci pas moins permis de
construire
les jeunes
c'est tout à son honneur d'ailleurs mais
cette pudeur des hommes politiques qui
ne prennent pas ils ne prennent pas la
télé jusqu'à sept ans maintenant
[Musique]
ras
hu
mais si victoria abril
[Musique]
ça
qu'est-ce qui est avant toute chose
merci d'être venu enceinte jusqu'au cou
c'est vraiment sympa pour les michel
dumont j'y suis enceinte et de 2000
enfants vannage afrique
tout le monde a remarqué à quel point
victoria abril qui travaillaient sur
indices depuis des années
chante bien
[Musique]
a gardez vous
bien elle est bonne celle là
et ce qu'est né ce qui scelle la prise
des pneus tout de suite à la touche et
la mêlée mais sinon c'est la loupe et
nano pay as you pay
[Musique]
alors victoria abril la semaine dernière
lou doillon était là et on se disait que
si elle épouse et garou elle
s'appellerait et cette semaine cette
semaine pensez de constater que si vous
pouviez david beckham vous seriez
victoria beckham aux mineurs oui c'est
l'épousé d'un chef de cas de gars à fort
électorat sèchement coupé au montage qui
sera témoin c'est davantage de prêtres
du cac mais comme on va nicolas wii
vient à d'ailleurs il m'a dit que plus
jamais tu vas brasse
[Musique]
et
oh
mais
tu voulais bien faire une crypte les
friches page de la bo houss nicolaj
demba téléspectateurs que nicolas a
remplacé gérard qu'est ce qui se passe
ne m'avait en à bras sans le coriace et
pas très grave c'est que du désir on a
réparé et que si ça se dit pareil en
espagnol
merci j'en ai alors pedro almodovar il
va bien très bien
la fois que je vous ai vu à la
télévision vous étiez sur scène à cannes
oui parmi les cinq actrices fétiches de
pedro almodovar niée par les coréens à
c'était courir ces japonais moi comment
on dit le festival est ouvert encore et
là tu viens de commander délateur on va
rester dans le cinéma donc quand vous
êtes à l'affiché victoria abril de cause
toujours
oui de jeanne labrune absolue d'abord
c'est une femme est ce qui est pas
souvent dans le cinéma
bon vous vous connaissez quelqu'un zim
la face est pas souvent c'est un petit 5
% et puis c'est extrêmement intelligent
et mais c'est vraiment leur riez pas
c'est vraiment extrêmement intelligent
ce sont des rencontres et à répondre et
arrêtons les hypothèses bien pas du tout
dans le coup
oui nos noms comme les api bruno bande
annonce
serge manière illégale
alors donc j'étais les fiches de
koztoujours de jeanne labrune avec jean
pierre darroussin sylvie testud claude
perron didier bezace et vous sortie le
28 juillet alors c'est difficile à peach
et ses deux jeunes la brume s'est pas
c'est pas évident à peach et c'est
intelligent ce niveau mais je ne vous
avais pas et vous n'êtes pas allés à
l'école c'est quand même moi la france
l'espagnol qui s'est chargé frange des
cils ça veut dire je vais pas essayer ça
qu'on la défend c'est pas parce que là
ça va mal finir
non non c'est un film sur le soupçon et
son contraire la confiance alors un
ouais c'est bien visuellement c'est un
film qui par dd tu sais cette sensation
et c'est la nouvelle mode c'est de nous
[ __ ] des nous venons sur un des
panneaux [ __ ] de nous mettre de nous
filer de la peur et à travers la
télévision nous file de l'apr sensation
de la sécurité donc là il raconte ça à
travers mon personnage que si tu fis
absolument charmante et formidable qui
tout d'un coup ils matinée c'est l'aide
et trouvent des moucherons des mythes
dans sa cuisine
donc je commence à s'agacer faire voir
par à la paranoïa il commence à vouloir
les exterminer d'abord elle essaie de
faire ça de façon écologique
et puis petit à petit comme ça la valise
et quand son mari ou puisqu'elle a du
sens qui est ce la malaria nous fait un
truc des jeux et la campagne qui est
vraiment et prévenir des interprétations
vous savez dans le gros guide dominique
besnehard vous
si ce sont des insectes rampants ou des
insectes volants qui a compris oui c'est
très très sympathique
alors là dessus arrive sylvie testud
donc est votre ami et qui vous propose
de partir à la campagne avec votre jules
darroussin mais en fait ça fait les
deuxièmes sylvie testud ne veut pas
partir gilles qu'est ce tu ne veux pas
partir car elle a flashé sur muet
oui je sais car la fesci sur un muet
c'est vrai oui mais qu'on croit qu'ils
les légionnaires et qui l'a été ce qu'il
a été et qu'il a été mais il est mieux
parce qu'il a été presque gorgé a dit
guti et doit s'aimer de la bonne je dis
ça craint de voir tout ça ça nous fout
de la couille en même temps de
l'excitation
il est muet donc ils me suivent jusqu'à
une maison de campagne
il a tous les amis toute la bande se
retrouve autour de se muer qui bien
entendu je crois qu'on peut le dire sans
dévoiler le film n'est pas vraiment
mieux et un nom n'ont ni d'agir non plus
donc voilà il se passe rien voilà c'est
dit non je raconte pas le mec il se
passe rien bah non non surtout pas je
raconte pas parce que là on revient tout
le monde par les couilles surtout ne
déflore non ça serait dommage ça serait
dommage de raconter la fin parce qu'elle
n'a pas évidemment il ya un truc qui
arrive et minc royal n'ont alors pas
être beaucoup plus sérieuses et c'est un
film sur l'ère du soupçon parce qu'il ya
un sens dans tout ça évidemment dans un
monde où chacun se méfie d'autrui celui
qui ne se méfie pas peut devenir celui
dont on se méfie le plus d une autre
façon de parler du film en même temps
que ça serait que vous regardez votre
caméra victoria abril et que vous disiez
magnéto serge magnéto serge s'il te
plaît aux brillances à des milliers
d'années la cage il est assez week end
c'est très bien que je déteste ça te
dirait du bien et aérer un peu sortir de
cette pollution
quand je pense générations entières
l'être humain se sont battus pour
construire des villes
tout ça pour que des citadins aisés et
oisive vient narguer dans les campagnes
des gens qui s'ils ont dû à mourir je
t'écoute des temps en temps je merci non
et heureusement pour toi je ne peux pas
saquer la campagne voilà vous pouvez
m'expliquer ce qui se passe
jacinthe fait les points et 8 ans de
lutte
parce que moi j'ai des moucherons quoi
que je fasse j'ai des mouches mais c'est
à nous y sommes sont rodés aux grandes
moi je vais des forces armées ne m'en
parlez pas c'est horrible excuse moi
j'ai dit non sont pas là dedans c'est
une discussion sans fil voix si vous
avez des moucherons je n'ai pas de
moucherons qu'est-ce que vous avez alors
mais je n'ai rien de madame tout va bien
vous êtes de quel signe j'ai pas de
signes et j'ai pas de moucherons c'est
clair l'oea a disparu tout le monde la
cherche ce bizarre ça c'est pas son
genre se fixer sur le nier c'est le
muguet qui travaille à la supérette
séparés avec lui ancien les unit avec
elle on peut s'attendre à tout je meurs
il a failli c'est ferrer qu'au rejet à
djibouti c'est curieux parce qu'au
moment maudit égorgé au zaïre
moi j'ai eu eric une fois c'est un type
étrange il y est entré
non mais tu te retournes surtout matin
mais des fous mais attention di maria et
moi qui peux pas regarder se meut et moi
j'aurais voulu savoir comment il était
exactement énorme heures brun et grands
et petits et dégarnis côtoiement
qu'est ce qui te facile chez les
légionnaires tue pas quitter sa 13è de
réunir sa clé je pense qu'ils sont
attirés par la violence ga même plus
loin je crois que le pousse à la
violence si tu savais ce que je prends
plaisir à faire tu t'es méfierais je
serais d'accord avec elle je pense qu'au
fond on est tous plus ou moins en bon
moi je peux vous dire avec laurent me
raconte que les truc glauque des trucs
de viol sodomie et ce travail est écrit
j'ai ton oui
donc je crois que jacinthe a raison de
s'attaquer à ces insectes je pourrais
pas en avoir mon bureau c'est bien trop
tels qu'ils sont nuls
[Musique]
qui pense toujours
le jeune la brunel et victoria abril
jean pierre darroussin ghz et le zares
voilà voilà
alors maintenant on va parler d'une
chose un petit peu moins un petit peu
moins drôle c'est les orphelinats
d'afrique
oui mais j'arrive avec plein de bonnes
nouvelles par morales autres oui alors
depuis on n'a pas de son enfant même à
2000 enfants qui mange à sa faim et qui
vont à l'école il y a dix orphanage et
si ce temps qu'on a mis un place avec
des dispensaires médicaux avec des
granges avec des cailloux et des épaules
et des oeufs
la protéine ah c'est ça qui manque et
notre orphelinat à nous il a augmenté à
donc maintenant on a fait avec l'argent
qu'on avec on avait des ambitions on a
de la terre il y en a fait un nouvel
orphelinat mais là c'est l'orphelinat de
notre rêve celui que j'aurais aimé être
quand j'étais moi-même dans un hospice
on l'a fait à la façon de là bas comme
les villages de la barre en terre cuite
avec de la végétation c'est ont duré les
clubs un tellement c'est magnifique et
ça sert à des plus grands verres
orphelinat pour les enfants que les
institutions normal ne veulent pas les
enfants sidéens les paralysies
cérébrales c'est à dire tous ces enfants
qui sont qu'ils sont
voilà voilà c'est une superbe a donné
ils sont tous sains et randonnées sur
toulouse mais mais mais le problème
c'est qu'il y en a certains les traits
malades que les institutions existantes
ne les accepte pas et d'ailleurs c'est
bien parce que quand on met des enfants
malades à côté des enfants malades et
ils sont 250
évidemment les petits sidéens tu vas qui
va tout simplement arrivé dernier à la
bouffe donc il faut vraiment absolument
les séparer on est en train de faire un
orphelinat juste pour des enfants qui
ont le sida parce qu'il y en a tellement
qu'il faut carrément ouvrir un quai pour
eux et sinon et voilà assis j'ai une
bonne nouvelle regarde j'ai t'amène ça
s'appelle c'est les veuves du ghana qui
les font et c'est etc mais ça s'appelle
by jove love les chiennes de l'amour ça
là-bas tout les fils et les seuls les
selles bijoux qu'ils ont su qu mais ça
ses portes à même la peau tu vois comme
chanel numéro 5
alors elle les met sur la ceinture et
normalement il met en d3 en avant moi je
trouve que trois c'est les plus jolies
et tu mets ça à même la peau et il faut
que ça tombe je dis ça tombe bien c'est
c'ui septembre sur le pubis d'accord
c'est extra lassé voilà ça c'est
magnifique c'est manger un peu beaucoup
et voilà donc que si vous achetez ça
chez paulette ses collègues qui a il a
la gentillesse des prendre la rue
saint-honoré
voilà si vous voulez ça vous fait
plaisir aux aux rêves et aux enfants
donc voilà
une association non mais comment marino
par mur
mais sinon la dre sa mère du fils voilà
bien quand vous êtes seul avec vous-même
victoria abril vous êtes fière de vous
vous êtes contente de vous je me demande
même pas j'ai pas le temps mais on va le
faire on va faire une interview
monologue
[Musique]
ça
victoria abril donc là c'est vous avec
vous même hein qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand vous venez sur un plateau de
tv il faut y aller
ouais ouais c'est dur non non non qu'est
ce que vous vous dites quand vous vous
levez le matin un corps une belle
journée mais surtout s'il fait gris
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous vous
entendez parler français voilà qu'est ce
que vous dites quand on vous reconnaît
pas dans la rue hijo de puta non non non
et j'ai connu la gloire à 14 ans à 22
ans je ne pouvais plus c'est pour ça que
je suis venu en france non et quand on
méconnaît pas dans la rue ça veut dire
que je peux encore être voyeur c'est ça
qui me plaît
coquine qu'est ce que vous dites quand
vous regarder dans un miroir et demi
j'étais gier mais heureusement que des
puits à non un truc comme ça je vois
plus bien sa lunette ar rêté comme à la
fin il était au top
et tout ça devient dieu a bien prévu des
choses parce que nous on vieillit on se
voit on se voit pas ce qu'est voit la
belgique a bien joué mais on a des
problèmes tu vas insidieux berry s'est
passé les fêtes et je n'ai pas vu voilà
ici j'avais pas vu comment vous est
coiffée par exemple non je trouve que tu
veux non je plaisante et 13 ans mais ici
c'est ici que mon corps mais j'étais
bien ce que je suis sorti la veille tout
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
retrouvez seul le soir je me trouve pas
seuls et saab
et puis quoi encore qu'est ce que vous
dites que vous avez envie d'abandonner
ce métier jusqu'à faire
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
regarder le journal télévisé
encore encore
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
jouez à poil rendre les ventres
d'ailleurs les autres si tu vois je fais
des fétus maintenant donc faire un tour
ils viennent les épauler collet et tout
le reste
si elle reste détendue conquis qui
conquit qu'ont donc tout ça bien dure
elle a été défendue non mais je sais je
connais cette technique de la connaît
c'est magnifique il ya que ça qui est
bien on va durcir leurs ancêtres voilà
qu'est ce que vous vous dites que vous
embrasser un garçon au cinéma et qu'est
ce que vous dites que vous embrasser un
garçon s'est dit elle très bien répondu
non eh ben j'ai dit à sa maquillage de
les donner un chewing gum
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous
embrasser une fille cinéma qu'un
j'aimerais appareils moulante à bienne
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous n'avez
pas confiance en vous elle pointe
chewing gum et non respect d'âge on
respire on respire et tout ça c'est du
mirage en le gardant présent il n'y a
aucune raison que ça marche pas cette
fois ci tu respires à trois fois c'est
juste un mirage il n'y a aucune raison
ouais qu'est ce que vous dites que vous
êtes prête à tout casser
respire aussi parce que c'est beaucoup
mieux de ne pas tout casser
quand vous touchez la drogue qu'est ce
que vous dites mais espérons en tous six
à quatre campus plus la drogue
d'ailleurs et j'ai arrêté de fumer régal
très bien cette nouvelle façon de
communiquer il y a des petits trucs dans
une truc gémit des petits boulots de la
q2 a marché qu'est ce que vous vous
dites que vous voyez un mec canon canon
que tu veux dire quoi canon le mécano à
camoël à bouinan pressé on a été quand
même d'une semi 14 mai le journal met
plein pied pendant longtemps bien non
ces voiliers souvent tu te vois souvent
tant qu est ce que vous vous dites quand
vous tromper nicolas g 30 jamais nicolas
achètent du vin ailleurs le seul mais
violent là et on marcel guillaume et
violent dans les programmes télévisés
comme toi on peut y arriver message un
an dénoncé l' héroïne on parle pas de
geste tu vois ce que je vais dire non
j'adore gilles mcc l'amour de ma vie ah
ouais si ya deux matches tout laissait
très bien que moi j'y suis et
monogrammes à ça veut dire partager leur
espagnol revient pas sérieusement
victoria il est mieux que gérard elle va
écouter
et non il est pas non il est pas mieux
que gérard gérard c'est lé père de mes
enfants c'est sacré ça et ça qu'est-ce
qui fait mieux qu'un retour aux cartes
aux dents arthaud lo kèr tôt le premier
c'est imbécile
c'est la dernière chose qui m'a dit
c'est un imbécile ça fait 20 ans que je
les vois pas un n'a fin capte s'étaient
séparés ou des 3,4 en europe
je mets les rencontres ivre morte - à 6
heures du matin entraînées sortie d'une
discothèque en donc ton qu'ils
m'arrêtent il me dit est ce que tu as en
espagne en clair à temps il est
également deuxième langue alors il met
10 es tu vas il met régates seront
sûrement j'étais un petit peu moins de
plus comme on est quand on a maintenant
elle a bien bien danser bienvenue et la
présidente
bien entendu quoi donc il met 10 octobre
à caen ce lundi donc et stages massacra
tu sais tu es plus tu vas pas le pas
freiné un peu plus cette démarche est il
de la digos des rires
c'est ce que je vous dis oui je suis
marqué tellement jerry brown voilà et
tout de suite après j'ai commencé à
monter les escaliers pour poule très
bien tous les biens et j'étais ravi du
duo quelles bonnes réponses j'étais ravi
des mois et tu n'apprécies pas rentrer
dans un truc à bosser plutôt nom n'a
plus jamais revu à retour au 2 mai
[Musique]
mais faire ça je viens plus jamais bien
ben tu vois ça avec nous oui oui thierry
lhermitte je vous salue aussi beaucoup
bergé
le chemin qui les mène
pas très sympa thierry lhermitte à vue
ouais pas très sympa c'est vraiment le
sale type
[Musique]
ça c'est vraiment le club des fondeurs
celui-ci on trouve pas métier mon
paternel ne faut pas tourner le dos et
la citrouille ou c'est vraiment la
collision de récré à côté 1
kérity sortes de films ainsi de toiture
est appliquée merci messieurs
m
longueuil
même son petit retour m'a déçu il aurait
pu
[Musique]
kouassi franck dubosc
du buzz que vous connaissez victoria
abril
non moi oui elles n'ont pas encore pas
encore ma faim je deviens rue vésale
maquillage est beau il est beau
non messieurs après qu'elle a year je
vais demander whisky et a réussi cébron
salle tellement bien
c'est vrai que c'est une soirée yeux
bleus après thierry lhermitte franck
dubosc francs que vous connaissez guy a
lepage
oui c'est un gars là je vais présenter
tout le monde en parle au québec je
viens d'apprendre ça oui oui va se
mettre aux chemises noires à la drogue
et tout ça il va s'appeler guy à la page
apparaît alors il est très très connue
au canada c'est le le le c'est toi qui
écris aussi
voilà d'où il a vendu un gars une fille
l'a vendu dans 27 pays
tu es riche alors oui mais pas des
riches alors les orphelins en afrique
voilà non mais bon dieu parce que moi je
cotise à vision mondiale depuis 1981
c'est alors d'enfants que j'ai tiré à la
vision mondiale depuis 1981 je traduis
de saint-pascal québécois j'avoue que
j'ai du mal
donc mon enfant maintenant 31 ans et
avec l'argent que je vais dernier s'est
acheté une compagnie de gens du
voisinage mais tire il est détesté au
canada non il n'est pas détesté il a été
controversé parce qu'il a fait un
commentaire sur la langue québécoise
mais on est plusieurs à le regarder sur
tv5 que sept ou huit ans je crois
oui ce chiffre qui est donnée là bas est
ce que vous savez que franck est très
connu aussi une star mais franck est
connu dans tous les pays du monde un
atout sur route non je veux dire une
connerie et l affiche de au secours j'ai
30 ans une comédie légèrement dramatique
de marie-anne chazel avec pierre palmade
giovanna mezzogiorno nathalie corré
françois morel arnaud giovaninetti et
vous sortie le 23 juin voilà alors j'ai
vers l'histoire ont versé trois amis
pierre palmade giovanna mezzogiorno
nathalie corré qui ont quitté l'île de
groix à l'âge de 18 ans pour débarquer à
paris et ils se sont fait une promesse
quand ils sont montés à paris sont fait
une promesse ne jamais se quitter est
toujours se serrer les coudes et et 12
ans plus tard le bilan est un peu mitigé
palmade il est heureux l'huile est assez
heureux en ménage avec un dénommé
alfredo il s'éclate dans son boulot
d'attaché de presse
giovanna mezzogiorno elle c'est pas du
tout pareil
elle vit seule en attendant des hommes
et nathalie corré capitale de la corée
[ __ ] baladeuses nord et sud ouais nan
pen dont guillaume garot et séoul en bas
lundi les capitales avant de venir mais
tout le savez thierry non séoul oui
j'aurais dû le trouvais séoul la rue bah
oui séoul alors nathalie corps est
entièrement dévoué à françois morel
capital de maurel attends je le sais
c'est pas facile non je sais pas je sais
pas c'est une blague c'est un nom
d'acteur soit morel l'acteur qui
étrennera que j'aurai du salon donc bon
soir montréal qu'un petit prof
égocentrique et mesquin et qu'ils
abaissent mal et comme il la baise mal
elle bouffe la baisse très très mal
c'est assez drôle d'ailleurs je me
revois et ses lacs palmade et ses lacs
palmade annonce à ses deux amis deux
nouvelles une bonne et a bien fait de 5
tout à l'heure ça hyper bien fait le
débarquement toi avec un briquet a gardé
des gestes à deux nouvelles une bonne
c'est qu'il est séronégatif et la
mauvaise c'est qu'il a le cancer et la
larme en arrive là conscient de la
fragilité de l'existence palmade va les
obliger
giovanna à aimer un homme et nathalie a
largué françois morel voilà ce livre la
vie qu'il s'était promis de vivre la
fête et ils ont trente ans c'est le
constat qu'on fait à 30 ans quand on
voit qu'on a voulu compenser qu'à 30 ans
on serait tel ou tel personnage et puis
là ils le sont pas vraiment ils vont se
forcer à la lettre c'est pas mal raconté
non ouais c'est bien raconté ou et c'est
c'est très bien très moi j'avais demandé
à marie-anne chazel d'appeler le film au
secours je n'ai plus 30 ans ouais il m'a
dit franck tu n'as pas le rôle principal
donc elle a gardé au score j'ai 30 ans
qu'est alors vous vous êtes un acteur
raté dans ce film à givet dans ce lit
pas les attax facile du fait des pubs
minable tout un dragueur d'un second
john et keith hackett une star soit
disant au canada il le dit il a tourné
dans le secret du lac a une feuille
temps qui viendra bien mais qu'en fait
c'est pas malheureux quoi c'est un
pauvre type s'est il fait il fermement
pitié et enfin en tout cas dans le film
il fait plutôt rire que pitié mais c'est
moi quand je les ai vus jeu je fais pas
de cinéma vraiment aura et j'ai vraiment
vu le film en spectateur et je me suis
fait je me suis ému et inspiré de quel
acteur français deux mois plus sévère de
moi je suis mais ceux ci n'auront que
dany brillant a dit en parlant de franck
dubosc qu'il était un acteur nietzschéen
c'est vrai accord à cette phrase de
nietzsche excellente
je ris par excès de tristesse tellement
belle phrase je crois que tout est dit
merci
alors ya je crois pas que nietzsche et
un jour si tu es du dany brillant
non non non alors il ya thierry
lhermitte dans ce film 1 il est à peu
près dans tous les films bien tiré moi
j'ai pas beaucoup tourné mais en général
quand je tourne il ya tellement de la
production cgtr je ne sais pas si c'est
moi qui monte c'est celui qui demande
j'ai l'impression que thierry lhermitte
demande à ce que font du lot ce soir du
dégât il entre dans un restaurant ils
vous ignorent et vous vous dites à la
gonzesse avec qui vous êtes il me fait
la gueule depuis que j'ai piqué un rôle
oui je précise à ceux qui m'entourent à
table que c'est thierry lhermitte
j'essaie de l'ermite excellent comédien
ouais y'a qu'un truc vous avez déclaré
là quand même c'est très fort si le film
avait été réalisé par un homme
je n'aurais pas accepté le rôle ouais
non c'est vrai
non parce que je vais vous dire c'est le
personnage me ressemblait tellement
enfin ressembler parce que je faisais
sur scène au départ je suis si c'est une
femme que je le dis tout de suite à
marie-anne chazel la marie-anne chazel
je lui ai dit tout de suite que que
j'avais pas envie de me rapprocher trop
de faire que ça la russie quoi elle m'a
rendu humain est un homme mort est
rendue que rigolo elle elle m'a rendu
humains et j'avais envie qu'il ne nous
avait pas dit ça comme ça c'est les
femmes clavier il est passé sur le
tournage il tournait clavier tourner un
film encore ça oui donc il prenait il eu
je crois qu'ils le voyaient les rushes
et tout ça mais il tournait à notre film
vous ne connaissez pas bien non on s'est
croisé à la sortie du film à la
projection du film et tout ça n'a pas
une saloperie a balancé pour durer alors
en jeu non parce que j'en ai pas à dire
moi je vous savez c'est passé marianne
qui m'a choisie dans le film et
il a été pour elle m'a fait des
compliments sur mon interprétation et et
moi me fait rire au cinéma donc je vois
pas bien comment je pourrais à dire du
mal vous avez vu la vérité à vous me
fait rire aussi français plus après tout
bon voilà pourquoi vous tournez avec la
femme c'est toi que j'ai aimé les fils
du mari en même temps bon voilà mais ne
me faites pas dire quelque chose que je
n'ai pas voulu dire non vous n'avez pas
dit si vous avez vu la vérité je n'ai
pas vu mais vous savez quoi la dernière
fois que je suis venu vous m'avez
demandé
bah oui parce que j'aimerais vous le
voyez pas plaisir l'impression ces
centres il faudra à guy penser à cette
question dès qu'ils invitent il faut lui
demander avez vous vu lovely rita
voilà ça sert à ça c'est une question
importante alors maintenant vous allez
faire un truc très compliqué vous avez
regardé la caméra avec vos yeux
magnifiques vraiment la caméra et vous
avez dit remaniée t auxerre nuitées
lèvres comment di resta en espagnol ou
mec t'as tes lèvres
non pas que la vie mais on fait comme ça
n'ont pas muté la venue d'auxerre
j'avais pas compris le but mais je suis
naïf si naïf
huit élèves aux mondiaux alors comme on
dit en espagnol magnéto serge nous
rappelle de la bfc mourad mombasa où
soyez tout est foutu
en 300 moi quand je les aurais je pu
crucifier je te jure pas moi en palais
je sais pas pourquoi je prédis findus
tout avait commencé ici je pourrai vous
étiez au courant
et puis comme ça parce que je me suis
pas de clash en ce mois
à
on sait jamais
[Musique]
les hommes s'entendre pour bouger au chu
de merde en comble et les femmes bougent
pour avoir de la tendresse suite mais
dans quelle catégorie tout ce qu'il te
plaît
les deux mois j'ai une bonne
et une mauvaise nouvelle
je commence à me sauver notre promesse
[Musique]
votre tour de la terre
tu vas quitter toi et si on se mouille
et nous de parler n'importe quoi cas
signalés en cloque mes copines toi cathy
je couche jamais rendez vous alors ça ça
tombe bien parce que moi non plus tu as
vu la bête c'est une illusion qui mena
d'un jt
une histoire de rien
[Musique]
non tout ça me choque personne que
jamais vu
si tu dis ça c'est du cinéma quand même
tu fais pas souvent
ah non non non non c'est l'angle sa jupe
recteur moi c'est quoi la caméra mais
que dalle mais rien je suis pas acteur
du tout d'accord là je veux moi je fais
que du one man show au début de l'été
voir sur l'écran
ouais si tu veux comment je t'explique
ça au début je vais faire de la scène je
me dis je vais être un comique machin et
puis manque de pot ça marche donc
donc je reste sur la scène et je fais
pas de cinéma alors je voulais faire du
cinéma grâce à la scène et maintenant je
fais du cinéma
alors c'est agréable oui c'est reposant
il est tranquille
ouais et voilà donc je peux me regarder
sur l'écran flatter mon ego et hughes
arrive à sa flotte et c'est ce qui fait
de mieux c'est bien un truc ça alors
autre actu autre actu mon cher franck
dubosc vous avez commencé à rôder votre
naruse des zac 1 rodez tournée en
province nouveau spectacle qui s'appelle
romantique
vous parlez de véro qui vous a quitté
vous deviez partir tous les deux à los
angeles entre temps elle s'est cassée et
vous y aller seule à los angeles et vous
retrouvez face à la mer avis nice beach
en train de chialer
c'est insupportable et vous vous dites
je vais en faire un spectacle exact bien
raconté c'est exactement ça un peu et
j'étais très triste me suffisent mais
c'est la vraie vie ça ah oui ça c'est
pas le spectacle la vraie vie dans la
vraie vie ma vraie verrou est parti j'ai
eu ce que je méritais et puis moi
pourquoi les partis mais pourquoi les
revenus
les partis parce qu'elle en avait marre
de moi et comment peut-on en avoir marre
de vous franck en vivant avec imagine
toi le dvd toute la journée
elle est partie en gros combat pour de
plein de raisons on skie toujours on
sait jamais pourquoi les sexuellement ça
se passe et comment
victoria m'oblige pas à donner des
détails restent dans ton croissance est
un problème de classe tu peux parler les
pays torontois mais s'est enquis à une
autre personne qui peut écouter voir et
cetera tu peux pas l'obliger tu vois on
sait pas d'un cumul des relatiosn il est
avec son ex je lui fais je veux dire et
c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça qu'il
n'existe pas beaucoup
voilà je lui faisais peur jeu
comment je pourrais tu expliquer je
pourrais être montrée mais j'ai pas de
faire peur non plus at war non c'est une
question lui je vais dire quand ils
baissent c'est ça
alors les gonzesses à bout d'un moment
tu vois voilà bah ouais ils en ont marre
ça fatigue
terriblement je veux dire je suis
comment te dire sexuellement parlant on
va regarder à quoi ça ressemble je vais
dire encore une fois
magnéto serge magnéto serge au lit tôt
car voilà bon magnéto serge et que ça
saute à nous ça s'est passé n'est pas
vous embêter ray tout ça ce sont mes
affaires bon je suis célibataire mais
pour moi je n'ai pas ça merde on est
évident qu'il est tellement incroyable
et c'est en ces temps où se percer des
trous dans le dos
on fermait plus la porte des toilettes
ont baissé des poils dans la baignoire
on n'osait faire dp qui font du bruit à
nous quand tu nous tiens même et ses
frais au début on fait un peu attention
la tournée puis dis que c'est normal
par exemple la laine du réveil avec sa
maman venue au début le matin bon ben je
me levais discrètement pendant que
véronique de remuer encore j'allais dans
la salle de bain sans faire de bruit
après coup droit finlande
là je reviens tout doucement dans le lit
est lé nouveau l'oeil en plein dans le
mille
forcément j'étais proche évident mais
bien sûr hier soir avant d'aller se
coucher
ça c'est un truc qu'on fait + ou une
cette eau on se réveille avec la bouche
pâteuse irlande rats crevés derrière les
amis en six ans que l'amour n'a pas
d'odeur
on ne bosse ça s'appelle romantique
alors
duboscq à partir du 14 septembre
bataclan ouais franck oui comme vous
êtes un grand séducteur je vous demander
un petit peu quelques tuyaux
c'est quoi la phrase pour aborder une
fille à dieu vous préférez draguer ou
vous faire draguer me faire draguer mais
c'est rare
franck de ses anneaux non les non non
non non les fid rate pas me drague pas
non non non un bon gros ben non ils se
disent raul à l'ôter va me sauter dessus
j'ai une image vous avez besoin franck
j'ai besoin de faire l'amour pour aimer
ou des mets pour faire l'amour bon ben
moi je bosse je baise a justement tout
le monde dit vous êtes un bon fond du
boss est-ce que vous avez une spécialité
qui a dit que j'étais un bon coup qui
m'a dénoncé
si j'essaie de spécialité je vais vous
dire que j'y vais c'est l'amour moi
c'est un peu comme les photos j'aime
bien les prendre mais j'aime pas dessus
voilà j'aime bien entendre sous fruits
mais c'est pas une spécialité sinon
référence vous préférez faire l'amour à
combien à financer la question est
pertinente à trois pas mal ah non c'est
pas une invitation je parlais avec deux
filles apparaissent cousin fontas menons
réalisé franck faire l'amour avec une
contractuelle sur une voiture mal garée
ouais ah ça c'est quoi la zone la plus
érogène chez vous comment vous expliquez
le spa ouais vous êtes le spa vous
connaissez le stage pas c'est entre
autres le trou du cul et les testicules
c'est pas vraiment le trou du cul
sparrow mois des véhicules avec laquelle
des personnes ici présentes n auriez
vous faire l'amour franck où la
discipline mais ça ça m'excite encore
plus victoria mutamba wemhoff à la
question déco et salle à cocher
licenciés d'admirateurs
je veux pas que ces deux nouveaux alain
delon forme du boss en tout cas j'ai
trouv sonner très mignon parce qu'il
ressemble au mien
avant on faisait ça on écoute le dantec
oui très haut niveau
on aime les gens passaient des faux-pas
par sévir tu nous lis pas alors là je me
déshabille et dit non tu vas madoré
nouvelle alain delon rond et on va lui
faire une interview alain delon
[Musique]
que pensez-vous de franck dubosc l'homme
je ne connais pas franck dubosc duboscq
ne se confie pas énormément fond du bois
ce qui est très discret bâtiment il se
confie à sa quéquette le soir dans la
déprime mais je ne fréquente pas
énormément franck dubosc pour vous
franck dubosc est synonyme de quoi enfin
tu vois ce qui n'est pas un synonyme
franck dubosc est haï tu es bon tu vois
ce que nul en orthographe bien
évidemment ce que vous pensez que franck
dubosc aujourd'hui devenu un grand
comédien franck dubosc n'est pas un
grand comédien
la comédie est un grand fan du bosquet
est-ce que vous pensez que franck dubosc
peut tout jouer notamment des merdes
[Rires]
alors franck dubosc ne joue pas dans des
mers de franck dubosc est de la merde et
je peux vous dire que beaucoup de gens
mûrs marcher dessus
est-ce que vous pensez que franck dubosc
laissera une trace d'un cinéma français
vient de le dire
est ce que franck du buzz aujourd'hui
atteint une certaine sérénité
l'enfant qui voit se connait pas serein
un boss peut éventuellement et pigeons
c'est bien franck dubosc aime les jeux
de mots foireux
est-ce que vous pensez que franck dubosc
va se mettre à la chanson
car franck dubosc est bon en tout
gayraud corps j'avais 20 ans je le cas
si on dubost viendrait alors là
est-ce que duboscq espère avoir bientôt
une rue à son nom
oui je vois ce qu'ils aimeraient avoir
une place non non il nous petit une
petite impasse en nickel les amoureux
pourrait marcher
l'un et l'autre s'embrasser sous des
portes attention à bien sûr bien
évidemment à s'embrasser sous des portes
cochères avec une lune qui descendraient
pour les griffons du bosquet poète une
très belle plume
on dit que font du buzz serait beaucoup
vu en ce moment en compagnie de top
model ils en pensent quoi franck dubosc
en kiosque
quand il est avec des top models ne
pense pas il baise est ce que franck
dubosc est fier d'avoir honoré toutes
les femmes qui se sont présentées à lui
on y bosse n'est jamais fiers ils ceux
qui encore énormément de travail à faire
franck dubosc plaisante
est ce que franck dubosc est une star au
japon
si le japon est un des pays du monde
franck dubosc est une star au japon
[Musique]
et j'y tiens
franck dubosc admire alain delon à l
inverse
reste à prouver
[Musique]
bien accueilli maintenant salam taxes
m
[Musique]
à
est ce que vous connaissez franck dubosc
retiens-tu malheureusement pas non
extraordinaire parce que quand même il
un regard vers moi c'est donc je suis
quand même pas que ce soir j'ai 31 ans
viêt irakien de bagdad c'est l'impact
évidemment c'est votre pseudo salam ça
veut dire la paix en arabe et pax ça
veut dire la paix en latin et puis c'est
un jeu de mot avec salman pâques qui est
une entreprise d'armement en irak alors
vous êtes devenu célèbre à travers votre
journal qui raconte votre vie
quotidienne à bagdad qui a été diffusé
sur internet en anglais ça s'appelle un
web blogs
quand on diffuse son journal sur
internet on dit aussi un blog et on vous
a appelé le blogueur de bagdad voilà
alors au départ c'est juste une
correspondance publiée entre entre deux
amis c'est pour ça que ça s'appelait
worries ride ou ra ed wright c'est un
ami à vous qui était parti faire des
études en jordanie
et puis votre log énormément de succès
des dizaines de milliers de lecteurs
quotidiens jusqu'à bloquer le serveur
certains certains jours et c'est vrai
que ce sont des textes en parfaite
contradiction avec l'image habituelle
qu'on se fait des désirs à kg 1 vous
parliez dans votre look de votre
obsession pour david bowie vous parler
du nouveau cd de massive attack et en
plus vous avez beaucoup d'humour
jusqu'au jour où le quotidien
britannique the guardian vous propose de
publier par écrit vos textes qui étaient
d'abord sur internet et ça passe très
bien du support électronique au support
papier
voilà on a dit que j'ai tjrs et lan
franck de la guerre d'irak alors
aujourd'hui vos textes paraissent sous
forme de livre un livre qui s'appelle
bagdad blog chez hachette littératures
alors l'intérêt du blog en l'occurrence
c'est finalement face à une information
je dirais hollywoodienne
un peu comme un jeu vidéo vous c'est
vraiment la voix de l'intérieur c'est
pour ça que ça a eu autant de succès non
on avait l'impression effectivement
d'assister à un jeu vidéo une production
hollywoodienne c'était quelque chose un
peu surréaliste et en fait je pensais
pas vraiment mais d'autres y repenser et
se sont rendus compte qu'effectivement
la plupart des rapports journalistique
était un peu irréaliste et là il y avait
une voix de l'intérieur une voix
véritablement irakienne qui a raconté
vraiment ce qui se passe et c'était
intéressant voir la réaction des gens
c'est exactement vous raconter ce même
pas que ces préparatifs des
bombardements là on est en septembre
2002 alors vous dites qu'en fait pour
vous préparer aux bombardements
vous allez acheter de l'alcool des bons
bouquins des trucs à grignoter
kalistick non c'est exactement ce qu'on
sait qu'il ya une catastrophe on a rien
sous la main pour empêcher c'est
l'arrivée de la catastrophe on reste
chez soi on ferme les fenêtres et puis
on prit alors le 12 octobre vous dites
je n'achèterai pas des petits drapeaux
américains pour accueillir les nouveaux
colons et vous comparez les américains
aux anglais en 1920 vous dites on n'a
pas besoin que le monde civilisé nous
donne des leçons à comprendre que l'un
des gros problèmes qui se posent en irak
actuellement c'est la façon dont nous
avons été traités à faire en tant qu
irakien on nous a montré très peu de
respect et je crois qu'il faut quand
même faire comprendre au monde que nous
sommes capables de
de nous défendre nous mêmes de nous
débrouiller tout seul on ne peut pas
forcer les choses on ne peut pas se
pointer dire voilà on va forcer la
démocratie ça marche pas l'insulaire ça
s'appelle de la dictature
alors ya enfin fin octobre salam pas que
vous êtes très critique avec les
boucliers humains vous dites les
boucliers humains on leur donne quinze
mille dinars par par repas et là bas en
irak ça permettrait de manger un mouton
entier ils ont leur corps ou peu
d'endroits ils ont le coeur sur la main
mais en même temps est magnifique
manifestement il été manipulé par le
gouvernement irakien s'est qualifié il
se rendait pas tellement content
et puis en même temps lorsque le
gouvernement irakien leur a demandé de
prendre place dans les écoles dans les
toutous dans les centrales de lino non
on va se faire tuer ils ont quitté le
pays à ce moment alors que ça allait à
contre-courant de ce qu'on voulait un
alors la guerre approche c'est
extraordinaire son truc parce que jour
après jour tu vois la guerre approchez
vous dit personne ne me convaincra que
la guerre est acceptable
vous êtes inquiet de la tacc évidemment
des bombardements mais surtout des
suites
et apparemment la suite vous à vous a
donné raison puisque on a vu que c'était
bien pire après qu'avant en décembre
2002 il ya un rapport qui sort sur les
droits de l'homme en irak et ça vous met
en colère parce que vous dites merci
d'avoir rien vu pendant trente ans c'est
à dire que vous reprochez à la
communauté internationale de
s'intéresser aux droits de l'homme en
irak
à quelques mois de l'invasion américaine
c'est exactement ça comprendre que tout
d'un coup du jour au lendemain les
américains débarquent
voilà nous venons vous libérer mais il
était pendant tout ce temps derrière le
régime de saddam pendant des années
qu'ils ont soutenu ces régimes barbares
pendant des années budget avant la
guerre et puis tout d'un coup comme ça
il se pose en tant qu opérateur ça
marche pas fait pas rêver
il faut être un peu cynique quand même
pour croire à ce genre de salade
il arrive comme ça comment peut-on
accepter une chose c'est un des préférés
il se présente en tant que libérateur et
nous connaissons leur passé ils ont
soutenu saddam pendant des années voilà
alors en internet un jour vous
roche la passivité des désirs à quai en
disant pourquoi ne se soulèvent t-il pas
ne se révoltent t-il pas contre contre
saddam hussein et vous répondez excuse
moi c'est pas grave de se faire [ __ ]
à coups de tesson brisées est arrivé à
un moment c'était rendu compte qu'ils
les aient craqué n'arriverez pas à ces
seuls 2,7 au régime était très puissant
pour coupait littéralement les têtes
jusqu'ici osé s'élever contre ces
tableaux qu'il fallait bien survivre
alors évidemment d'un profil bas mais il
en revanche on se rendus compte que les
jeux ne pouvait pas se faire sans une
intervention extérieure n'était coincé
le cul entre deux chaises signe alors on
accepte un côté la coalition qui vient
ou bien est ce qu on la refuse non on
voulait se débarrasser de cet âne mais
la seule façon c'était la guerre alors
les bombardements approche vous dit on
va nous démocratiser à coups de bombes
et c'est pas très bien parce que vous
dites que finalement les femmes voilées
des pieds à la tête
la séparation des filles et des garçons
le retour à la loi tribale qui remplace
la loi sont des choses qui sont arrivés
en irak après la guerre du golfe
yes ici m
j'espère que maintenant on se rend bien
compte les sanctions qui ont été
imposées à l'irak non ça ne fait rien de
bien nous avons vécu 10 années d'horreur
à cause des sceaux et n'ont fait de mano
fait aucun mal à ces dames mais au
peuple
alors voilà le 20 mars 2003 c'est la
guerre vous dites que saddam aillent au
diable et que bush l'y rejoignent ce qui
me semble pas seulement sur lequel tout
le monde pour être d'accord ici en tous
les cas
et puis c'est l'invasion et la boue dit
salam pacs les américains ne font rien
contre les pillages en fait date
ça nous a fait très mal parce que tout
d'un coup les plus de gouvernement
faisait confiance ces gens extérieurs
qui étaient censés assurer la sécurité
sous rester là les bras croisés devant
les pillages devant la destruction reste
hélas à se tourner les pouces alors que
c'est eux qui avaient les armes pour
nous protéger de l'opa fait alors du
résultat de tout cela c'est qu'on leur
fait plus confiance
ouais alors parlé de la chaîne de
télévision al djazira vous dites elle
est pire que jamais elle devrait être
interdite par le mollah brenner c'est à
dire que vous dites car je sais pas si
on lui traduit ce que tu dis parce qu'il
est écroulé de rire
il lui raconte des histoires de todo que
l'histoire allait effectivement se
termine cette théorie du jour au
lendemain j'ai pas tellement d'amour il
mélange un peu tout ce qui se passe en
irak j'appelle ça de la résistance
plutôt que du terrorisme alors que cette
autorité
al jazeera leur mentalité j'ai du mal à
la comprendre et le mollah bremer en
tout cas sur ce dossier aurait dû être
plus ferme or voilà vous raconter un
jour la fouille de votre maison
familiale par des soldats américains
mais d'abord c'est des gamins et alors
il vous soupçonne de recevoir des
soudanais une cellule
on était censé être une cellule
terroriste nouvelle en fait c'était en
fait c'étaient des ouvriers c'est quand
vous dites à la fin bravo les mecs vos
informateurs sont vraiment super
c'étaient des ouvriers qui venaient
travailler dans la cuisine de votre mère
et les américains les ont pris pour des
soudanais pas à l'école des terroristes
fait ou non alors sur l'avenir de l'irak
vous êtes relativement optimiste vous
dites qu'on passera par une phase de
libanisation de beyrouth ification mais
que finalement à la sortie de saab
c'est vrai que les gens aujourd'hui à
beyrouth yvan dans les boîtes de nuit et
vous pensez que ça peut se terminer
comme ça tout cas je l'espère ça prendra
du temps ça prendra beaucoup d'efforts
mais c'est le genre de choses auxquelles
aspirent on veut vivre une vie normale
on a perdu son quotidien on veut le
retrouver aujourd'hui la vie est
complètement bouleversé plus rien n'est
normal et on veut il faut être optimiste
il n'ya pas d'autre choix oui mais là la
montée du fondamentalisme chez les
jeunes par exemple 60% de jeunes sont
chômeurs en irak ce que vous dites
la montée du fondamentalisme va pas dans
ce sens là vous pensez pas que au lieu
de vous retrouver en train de danser à
une line up de l'évent retrouvées à la
mosquée en train de prier de force
non ils vont vouloir pour vouloir
construire plus de mosquées que deux
boîtes de nuit c'est vrai c'est une
source d'inquiétude mais enfin quand
même je pense qu'on va se débarrasser
des mollahs on va se débarrasser du
voile et on ira on ira dans les bottes
de dieu vous entende vue des élections
en irak
ça sera pas le liban se sera l'iran non
parce que c'est des chiffres qui n'ont
gagné actuellement en tout cas se
présente comme ça j'ai bien peur que les
chiens étaient que les chiites ne leur
rapporte sur le modèle iranien c'est
très inquiétant mais qu'on peut quand
même espérer c'est qu'avec l'arrivée du
nouveau gouvernement la transition du
pouvoir peut-être que les choses ont
préparé les irakiens des véritables aux
élections et le spectre d'un pays
islamique n'est pas aussi inquiétant qu
ils n'étaient hier
ouais enfin les américains font rien
pour arranger les choses parce que vous
parlez de la prison d'abou ghraïb dans
le point de cette semaine vous dit en
parlant des sévices que les soldats
américains ont fait subir aux
prisonniers d'abou ghraïb c'est du porno
cheap c'est du mauvais sm et c'est pas
un accident c'est une volonté d'humilier
les arabes dans ce qu'ils ont de plus
sacré d'une certaine façon et c'est
intéressant cette affaire c'est à dire
que ce n'était effectivement pas s'ils
sont à pédales exactement dans les
angoisses donc
monde arabe bien qu'ils sont allés
chercher véritablement ces images
d'humiliation sommes attachés par ces
femmes ces histoires de d'image
homosexuels ça n'était effectivement pas
un hasard je ne sais pas par hasard six
ou sept personnes qui se sont amusés à
cela c'était prévu pour ouais c'est
comment la vie à bagdad aujourd'hui que
si on peut c'est une abstraction des
soldats des barricades des les murs de
béton des défis des explosions de tout
cela si on peut oublier tout ça est
belle la vie presque normale
vous dites si on se fait tuer y aura
personne pour enquêter c'est pas de moi
c'est un état hors la loi on peut se
faire assassiner kidnappé tout ça en
toute impunité c'est vraiment le far
west
alors vous avez beaucoup d'humour et
c'est vrai que votre bouquin est marquée
vraiment sceau de l'humour c'est
vachement bien écrit c'est très drôle et
ça fait penser un peu à ce que y b avait
écrit sur l'algérie à un moment c'est
même le mais ce prix alors vous dites il
nous faudrait un manuel du genre la
démocratie expliquée aux nuls et
j'aurais voulu qu'on amène ce livre ici
mais non alors je sais que j'aimais
beaucoup david bowie d'être fasciné par
david bowie j'adore je peux vous faire
écouter un remix de david bowie par
david guetta à monsieur
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît aux ja je veux juste
dire ces prêts classe mais rester là un
bon moment à parler et l'a pas sorti une
veine il aura pas de quartier les une
carte quand même non l'ap a sorti ses
vacances en venir de bagdad et à sortir
une
au début je veux dire c'est un film qui
sera bagdad un homme lequel attachement
mois ont estimé qu'il était trop pour
nos achats de gaz ils rappelleront la
censure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon j accueille maintenant l'ex-membre
de l'air
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir avec son anglais est journaliste
éditorialiste essayiste spécialiste en
géopolitique
ça veut dire quelque chose de beaucoup
de choses une rom non mais si bien en
tous les cas vous publié chez grasset un
avocat qui s'appelle l' odyssée
américaine où vous expliquer quelque
chose qui fera plaisir d'ailleurs à
saddam pacs l'amérique n'a jamais été un
empire voilà et ne souhaite pas en être
c'est le paradoxe d'alexandre adler
alors c'est gonflé quand même à une
époque où l'amérique qui a toujours été
un une solution qu'a toujours été un
recours devient un problème devient un
obstacle on se demande si elle ne tourne
pas le dos à l'occident tout simplement
et vous vous dites l'amérique n'a jamais
été un empire et ne sera jamais un ce
que vous dites et alexandre adler c'est
que l'amérique effectivement durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale et devenue un
empire malgré elle comme dit aaron brute
surcroît oui je crois qu'on a déjà de
surcroît la wii mais il faut bien
expliquer les choses parce que ça ne
ressemble pas aux autres
et alors justement on compare souvent
l'amérique l empire britannique
et alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que l'angleterre qui n'est pas non plus
un état monstrueux mais à élever des
générations entières de c2c meilleur de
ses meilleurs jeunes gens à mener par le
bout du nez le reste du monde
en gros dizaines de milliers de
fonctionnaires britanniques gouverner
300 millions d'indiens et ça marche est
relativement et bien l'amérique ne sait
pas faire ça 1 alors on peut dire qu'ils
sont beaucoup plus plouc qu'ils
connaissent moins bien le monde ce qui
est en partie vrai mais moi j'y vois
aussi une vertu c'est que cette société
est incapable de secret tesla et
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec un bon drive
je pense que dans d'autres pays on
aurait quand même mis un peu plus le
boisseau sur ce scandale il a il est
sorti formidablement bien et c'est pas
fini la commission denquête est en train
de montrer que donnera mme souad
connaissait les choses depuis un certain
temps et il va finir par sauter d'un
drone soldes
alors si vous êtes des arguments vous
dites par exemple avant ça avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
l'amérique a toujours été réticente à
annexer autre chose que des régions vide
c'est par exemple l'amérique n'a jamais
conquis le mexique ou le canada s'est
retiré c'est le canada n'a préféré
s'entendre avec les mêmes cuba il ya eu
mandement qui s'appelait l'amendement
platt il faisait de cuba à protectorat
américain sers la politique étrangère de
cuba étaient définis par les états unis
et puis en 33 roosevelt et dino non
l'argent rappelle un autre argument qui
va évidemment dans le sens de votre
théorie vous dit après la guerre quand
ya eu des bases américaines en allemagne
japon france maintenant tous les pays
qu'ils allaient dans les philippines
même voilà ils sont partis quand on aura
vraiment des partir mais oui alors
parfois avec amertume on en 66 en
briques autant les vins et les parfums
français pendant quatre à cinq mois et
puis depardieu a été laissée un peu
orphelin à châteauroux mais ils sont
partis alors vous dites par exemple
l'amérique n'a pas vocation à contrôler
la planète
elle est incapable de s'implanter les
etats unis sont capables de s'implanter
et de rester vous dit cette phrase je
crois que c'est talleyrand on peut tout
faire avec des baïonnettes sauf
s'asseoir de ce les américains c'est ça
que je vois n'ont aucun plan pour le
moyen-orient par le grand moyen-orient
la démocratie mais c'est plutôt un
argument de vente interne parce qu'en
fait ils ont dans un grand moment
réflexe casser le régime de saddam
hussein sont bien en peine aujourd'hui
de trouver quelque chose et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans les environs
il ya des gens qu'ils ont plein d'idées
par exemple les iraniens eux ils savent
très bien ce qu'ils veulent faire de
l'irak et ils vont le faire nous dit que
les baïonnettes ca sert à tout se
faisait asseoir dessus et puis vous dit
que finalement maintenant dans chaque
pays une conscience nationale qui fait
que c'est très difficile de couper des
gens national régional 10 révoltes voilà
les américains dites-vous non marché sur
bagdad pour en repartir alors ça fera
plaisir à notre ami je suis persuadé de
sa lame pacs vous dites qu'en fait ils
vont pas eu non pas rester pour vous il
s'agissait simplement de faire peur au
monde arabe
oui à d'abord à cause de ben laden qui
les a défiés le 11 septembre comme en
août trade center et sa dame qui s'en
est réjoui pour vous c'est une raison
importante
j'ai pas de corrélation entre ben laden
et saddam mais c'est vrai que
contrairement à arafat qui a donné son
sang pour mater rutan vrai contrairement
à l'iran car il ya qui a donné des
condoléances aux états unis ont dénoncé
la naissance
réjouit le 11 septembre et pour vous
j'ai la seule raison de le nom mais
comment dire ils disent 'voilà et il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'états arabes qui sont
mis dans un mauvais qu'à celui là oui et
on va montrer de cordes qui en fait
c'est ça pour vous lire accès uniquement
pour montrer qu'on ne touche pas
impunément aux états unis et je suis là
vous avez raison et kadhafi ni lui a
mieux compris ça et bien il s'en est
tiré il a payé ces indemnités aux
amériques après il avec voulait plus
payer à la france et il a accepté
démanteler son programme nucléaire c'est
fini ouais alors effectivement il ya un
fait qui va dans votre sens c'est que
les états unis n'ont pas en irak la même
volonté de reconstruction qui l'ont eu
au japon en allemagne c'est vrai qu'ils
sont pas là pour rester vous avez
peut-être vu que leur ami ahmad chalabi
que maintenant on appelle à washington
le résistant attaché-case grain s'est
fait perquisitionner milliers par les
américains c'est à dire que l'idée de
mettre des clients des états unis au
pouvoir est bel et bien fini d'ailleurs
ni le premier ministre
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit ni le
président actuellement ne sont des
clients des états unis à proprement
parler la thèse de vos quatre en tête
c'est que les états unis rentrer à la
maison
oui et que l'aventuré irakienne n'est
qu'un épiphénomène et qu'enfin tôt la
fin d'un cycle
voilà qui a commencé avec l'arrivée des
deux hitler au pouvoir en 32 des
japonais en chine et c'est le dernier
épisode
je n'en vois pas d'autre vous êtes un
peu d'accord avec salam taxe est
optimiste vous croyez pas l'apocalypse
vaut pas en irak en tout cas un je pense
qu' un pays qui est beaucoup plus
apocalyptique
c'est malheureusement le pakistan le
pakistan avait instruction pakistan dans
les normes qui se veut dire que ce que
vous dites vous c'est que les pilotes ou
et qui ont tapé dans le wall trade
center n'ont pas été formés dans des
écoles de pilotage américaine c'est
impossible
vous dites qu'ils ont été formés au
pakistan j'ai demandé à six personnes
différentes parce que cette histoire me
me turlupine de maintenance comprend
mois de septembre tous des pilotes de
ligne chevronnés et c'est qu'ils m'ont
expliqué qu'on ne rentre pas comme ça
visuellement dans un dans une tour qui
est assez étroite sans avoir une bonne
formation ou alors une balise à
l'intérieur de la tour à une balise à
l'intérieur de la tour ça j ai pas pensé
moi j mois mais oui bah c'est bien
simple je pense que les services secrets
seraient très heureux de vous avoir
parce que c'est ce genre de question
qu'il faut se poser
moi je ne le suis pas posée mais malgré
la balise il avait coupé quand même le
gp a siphonné donc piloter à vue
c'est un exercice qu'on fait pour les
pilotes de ligne et un sur deux ne met
pas dans le dans le centre au début donc
en fait voyez c'est une science toute
récente que j'aime et
je me suis vraiment intéressé à ce sujet
et je pense que les écoles de pilotage
là où ils ont été c'est ce qu'on appelle
dans les services secrets une légende
enfin voilà donc penser qu'il faut se
battre avec ses pilotes ont été formés
au pakistan là où voulez vous c'est pas
en afghanistan non c'est pas en irak
comme il faut il faut il faut simplement
avoir par exemple un simulateur de vol
ouais des choses comme ça bon tout ça
existe au pakistan est un pays à la fois
moderne et fou c'est le plus dangereux
de tous les pays de loire et la vie
aussi mais il a raison il a parfaitement
raison
s'ils voulaient le pakistan a donné un
prix nobel de physique il a une pléthore
de gens qui savent fabriquer tout il n'y
a pas un avion un système automatique
qui fonctionne en arabie saoudite sans
des ingénieurs des militaires
pakistanais attaqueraient ce qu'ils sont
comme les indiens ce sont des indiens
dont qu'ils ont ce côté très développés
qui connaissent l'informatique la physx
à faire marcher les choses
et malheureusement ils ont aussi des
mollahs très retors alors la combinaison
des deux est explosif et je ne vois pas
pour ma part l'équivalent du pakistan
dans le monde arabe
on va ajouter une chose c'est que la
bombe atomique pakistanaise a été
financé à 90% par les saoudiens et donc
nous avons un vieux dicton qui dit que
qui donne qui paye la musique donne le
ton et que donc la bombe atomique
saoudienne est pas loin
qu'est ce que pense l exode rural un peu
aux états unis c'est naturel
il y en a moins parce que les mexicains
viennent maintenant dans ces régions vie
bon j'ai la très franche sur étrange
comme d'aller chez canon supplie le rang
il est capable
adler de parler de tout parlant des
heures faire très attention pas de
diététique porte à porte et on garde de
mon client portaient très bien
mary l'année car de très bons clients va
très bien
je
gera serrer la main
[Musique]
l élection de merci merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup il est fabuleux
jean
il dit
nous
jaurès
à
c'est tout
et maintenant mind
ma
[Musique]
si marina foïs
marina alors marina avant que vous
entriez sur les écrans de contrôle là
j'ai vu une jeune fille avec vous c'est
qui c'est olivier hamal cas l'attaché de
presse
elle est sympa way est très sympa elle
peut venir ne sommes pas des yeux olivia
olivia
[Musique]
non je voulais vous soyez là parce que
comme on va parler du film dans lequel
marina foïs joue et vous êtes son
attaché de presse à la pression voilà je
pense que c'est important que vous soyez
là pour voir si on parle bien du film en
gros il en train de vous dire qu'il voit
que vous lui plaisait énormément bien
les questions les chiites a pas du
boulot nord-est ian levine bien
alors un certain elle veut pas rester à
titiller un tu fais ta petite vous
respecte pas
on va tenir pause méline c'est à dire
que pendant 5 minutes mailing voire
d'aviation va faire des pauses
on parle du film maintenant parle du
film on parle du film je n'ai pas de
fiches sur médine
ah bon alors marina bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes affiche le 4 août d'un film qui
s'appelle je me sens pas belle de
bernard jeanjean avec julien boisselier
et là c'est un scoop énorme à le
préciser vous serez tous dans ce cinéma
là
ce jour là marina est à poil enfin ça y
est c'était arrivé marina est un auteur
à poil en retirant les voies sur les
épaules partout je peux pas dire mieux
toi tu as plus simple c'est qu'on montre
des images tout de suite après c'est
assez vendeur pour le film ça de dire
que marina est à poil ça peut faire
venir du monde
moi je pense le 4 août le 4 août et à
paris fait chaud c'est un peu chaud vous
avez envie de voir une belle gonzesse
apoel marina voilà le fébrile comment je
vends les films moi mais vous ne riez
pas dit j'aurais dû très vite je sais
vendre et alors ce que vous auriez
peut-être pas dit c'est que vous me mets
à la perfection le rapport sexuel et
leur gaz absolue je serai votre jules je
serais inquiet parce que vous aimez
tellement bien leur gaz que je me dis le
pauvre malheureux quand il va voir ça il
va dire une telle que fait pareil avec
moi parce que c'est le fait que julien
boisselier
c'est vrai j'aimerais que vous dites
j'aimerais que vous disiez le nom de
julien boisselier énormément de fois ce
soir je l'écrasé ce midi et je lui ai
promis qu on le dirait beaucoup sont non
seulement le dis encore une fois marina
ce soit sur mon nom c'est vrai que quand
on marina parle du film
elle évoque le tournage de ces scènes de
cul je crois qu'on peut le dire ça oui
c'est en ce sens oui c'est vrai que
julien boisselier
honnêtement ça va être très difficile
d'être une actrice dans ce cas là parce
que le réalisateur lui dis bon alors là
là je voudrais attention là tu va jouir
je voudrais
orgasme retenue mais en même temps ça a
l'air d'être le plus bel orgasme ta vie
ouais c'est ça et vous vous êtes là
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ces cas
là parce que vous arrivez le matin alors
moi la vérité c'est que j'ai perdu mon
cerveau c'est-à-dire que je pense et
j'étais très détendu je faisais ma
frimeuse gbowee à des scènes de cul un
film ça ne discute pas je les fais et
puis en fait j'en avais jamais fait et
le jour où jésus j'ai dû le faire
d'avoir j'ai passé au moins deux heures
à glousser comme une idiote et j'avais
honte quoi j'ai et et puis après au
moment où il a fallu que je chevauchent
julien toulouse ouais
julien boisselier et ben en fait je
savais plus j'avais plus de cerveau donc
je j'ai dit j'ai dû le dire quoi j'ai
dit à l'équipe j'ai dit pardon mais je
sais pas je ne sais pas comment il m'a
pas besoin de ton cerveau pour jouer ces
systèmes des misogynes
non je suis pas maison
si jamais tu vas te montrer comment il
fallait faire ce lié j'ai fait comme il
m'a dit et à réviser avaient cru en moi
j'y ai cru et puis je vous dire encore
une fois j'étais votre jules je me
méfierais parce que vous êtes une
simulatrice première bourre un extrait
tout de suite encore
d'abord on fait le pic est le pitch est
simple c'est toi je te veux je te baise
à c'est un peu le pitch oui bon ça très
petit résumé quoi vous êtes ça vous
embête que un peu trop résume un peu
trop résumé je te passe bien alors à toi
je te veux je te baise bien là ça va il
a bon là ou pas alors je vais raconter
l'histoire c'est une fille qui est déçu
en fait par ses aventures précédentes et
elle se convainc que la seule solution
c'est de draguer un homme vraiment
kouadiané d'être comme un mec est la
première victime c'est un ami un
collègue informaticien qui est venue de
province et qui est je viens boisselier
exactement bonne réponse de forme du
buzz voilà est alors à l'heure prévue
tout est prêt il ya de la musique douce
de la lumière tamisée un délire des
dessous affriolants qui est finalement
né voit bien être à la place 2 je viens
passion voilà
mais bien sûr rien ne se passera comme
prévu il passe une drôle de soirée à se
chercher avec cette réplique inoubliable
est ce que tu es julien boisselier non
elle est mieux mais mieux il réplique
dans le film qui vaut sont présents que
sais je te préviens le premier soir ni
fellation ni sodomie et ouais c'est un
peu normal en même temps pourquoi ne pas
faire c'est le premier soir
moi je suis avant de rencontrer la
personne ou saas et feuilles en centre-
discuter voilà mais c'est assez monde
heures pour le film je vous jure parce
que le 4 août les gens seront contents
qu avec moi c'est en valeur ces sirops
ces convois le lendemain oui oui on va
pas raconter la fin est le sus à la fin
on pas partie
non juste ça dit qu'elle fait rien de
comme elle dit qu'elle fera voilà vous
pensez que ça fait un peu trop films
pornos là non on a droit de faire un
petit prono une fois non mais une fois
dans une carrière c'est pas méchant
marina ça va pas marquer non mais c'est
une histoire d'amour ce film je veux
dire c'est quoi l'amour il ya un peu de
sexe ça il peut arriver que voilà elle
le gros début on va regarder le teaser
donc vous avez regardé votre caméra et
vous allez dire dit le normalement parce
que sinon c'est à partir de magnéto
serge magnéto serge voilà
[Musique]
non
oui aie aie aie
[Musique]
oh
je sens plus cette semaine chez bic puis
j'ai fait du poisson s'appuyant tout la
part voilà me sens belle elle marina
foïs et julien boisselier sortie le 4
août pas se contenter de la bande
annonce il faut aller voir le film
precious début je les aime beaucoup
d'abord j'aime marina et d'une parce que
marina est une fille qui à la fois joli
et drôle tu des adjectifs que deux ans
il fait déjà ses gagnants et voilà c'est
le double effet matin dans un car de
bonnes clients à tu peux y aller marina
c'est maintenant tu me les a retiré la
dernière fois avec l'argent versé 1 0 je
crois que j'ai fait beaucoup de mauvaise
vanne la dernière si on perd sa carte
quand on fait des mauvaises bases
ces normes avec sandra blair il avait
une carte bien j'ai dit on a perdu aussi
la dernière souviens toi et moi je les
fabrique dont je mens fois marina on va
jouer à un jeu tous les deux on va voler
ces noms bien alors marine ont bien joué
on va faire l'interview [ __ ]
[Musique]
marina vous l'avez l'album de benjamin
biolay
non mais oui mais c'est pas une afin moi
j'ai très peu d'albums un j'écoute
panunzi ouais vous l'avez pas une
référence non et il est mignon quand
même avec tous ses cheveux non il n'est
pas faux non benjamin biolay après je
pense qu'ici les mieux que quand il sera
chaude qui à la question vous portez des
converse avec vos jeans
évidemment les tonga la ville c'est bien
ah bah oui mais attendez j'ai plus
[ __ ] à la birkenstock argenté away
fait qu'un jeu de chez vous manger des
sushis combien de fois par semaine
carottes à y aller vous rêvez dans
l'offre vous pourriez aménagé à partir
d'une ancienne usine
ouais ouais ouais on peut vous croisez
dans quel endroit de la mode en ce
moment marina ma rue vous acheter des
bougies parfumées c'est trop sympa non
vous trouvez pas alors je veux y mettre
parce que j'ai envie d'être une très
bonne [ __ ] mais en fait spontanément
non 1 et donc peut-être pas une [ __ ]
finalement au quand même
par exemple vous buvez du thé okada est
exclusivement et non attention marina
est ce que vous vous laver les cheveux à
l'eau minérale salut [ __ ] 1 fois bien
sûr vous porter des fringues qui ont
appartenu à votre merde c'est trop
délire ça ils trouvaient le foot us
vous êtes mise au commerce équitable
c'est cool quand même d'aider les
pauvres non un moi j'adore les pauvres
et les chanter le générique de capitaine
flam c'est vachement second degré c'est
sympa très mais pareil j'adore le second
degré l'humain vous le trouvez comment
vincent mcdoom il est trop top
mais j ai alors pareil je le connais
très très peu parce que je regarde pas
trop la ferme je la connais très peu je
la connais très peu
ben voilà donc voilà
viola saint tropez cet été huawei et
l'hiver à l'île maurice
en février je ne sais pas où on va c'est
tellement tendance saint tropez même si
c'est ringard
bah ouais mais je vais y aller vous êtes
tombé amoureux d'un homosexuel récemment
veuve ouais mais bon donc il s'est rien
passé
la politique ça vous fait carrément chez
alors je vais me mettre à ce que ça me
fasse chier d'accord non mais non mais
non j'ai même voter aux européennes
nombreux pour qui j'ai voté socialiste
un trait mais ça leur a réussi selon les
ans des marchés un bravo mais alors
l'attaché de presse du film si vous
levez vous voulez le faire rentrer parce
que elle c'est pas la chef
quoiqu elle le mériterait d'être chef
mais bref c'est le sosie de françois
hollande aurait pu rentrer tout de suite
à je sais qui c'est c'est françois vrai
oui mais pense pas rentrer
bon sang
[Musique]
bonsoir bravo thierry cette émission
part au coup là ouais mais ça va on a
bien parlé du film non c'est pas mal
mais c'est une comédie un way et c'est
une comédie où on tombe amoureux qu'elle
a passées à rien a réduit un sens de la
passe et déciment comédie romantique
avec du rire et du sexe et de la santé
yeh flash derrière ou de plus de six ans
et que c'est pas mal pour le film moi de
mettre la licence en été c'est pas mal
en effet rien trop tuerie pete est un
peu déstabilisé puis beaucoup de sexe et
tu sauras tu rentres chez toi je pense
que quand tu rentres tu vas faire
l'amour mais direct inciter un
partenaire mondial mais sébastien bellin
donne une [ __ ] est en fait c'est pas
du tout une [ __ ] mon nom on vérifie
diallo germe génies en herbe à halle en
vérifie et son pote aussi ingénieur
boisselier wii fera brazza au canada oui
franc intéressant tomber l'idée c'est de
faire tout le monde en parle le canada à
partir du 12 septembre
ah bon ouais il a assuré qu'il arrête je
crois que finalement je vais animer love
story c'est lui qui a inventé un green
chic mais c'est lui
les milliardaires le mec 27 pays les
blindés ils blindés ça va moi aussi j'ai
un pel 1
marina est ce que vous préférez vous
dire ma carrière d'abord mon bébé
ensuite
bah oui alors ça c'est sûr mais tours
avant mes enfants et vous manger manger
bio c'est long ah non ben parce que
c'est bon pour la planète un oui mais
les graines non jab ross et le génial
marina non ouais
[Musique]
bonsoir il manquait des invités soit ou
quoi non pas du tout maintenant c'est
que nous on est toujours très intéressé
d'avoir l'avis des états chez vous vous
cassez bien sûr dans ce cas les rezéens
vicat karim
[Musique]
et maintenant et maintenant
il y a
aia
là
mais ségolène zinc
[Musique]
ça
alors tous les deux gagnent à 40 ans de
carrière 100 millions d'albums vendus 31
disques d'or
coulaines de gagne c'est ça
heures
obama
m
[Musique]
eh oui
lettre à ma mère
oui
[Musique]
là
mu à la la
[Musique]
kimmons
google
ça fait plaisir c'est tous les concours
de danse de mon adolescence qui repasse
l'abondance alors voilà donc vous êtes
tous les deux des membres fondateurs du
groupe d'abord robert kool bell
c'est vous et de nistos masse dit titi
c'est vous c'est moi à la robert vous
êtes bassiste et leader du groupe et de
nice thomas jette sax alto et vous
faites les vocaux
voilà vous êtes ici pour la sortie d'un
double cd qui s'appelle the hits
reloaded 28 tube de kool and the gang
repris en compagnie de superstars comme
jamelia blue ashanti jamiroquai sean
paul
jimmy cliff lorraine il youssou ndour
redman et évidemment dany bribes rtx qui
est dans fraîche voilà
je
[Musique]
orlando exige le pipe
non je n'ai 6
as tu ne paies
[Musique]
non
kool and the gang à l'olympia le 10
juillet voilà alors robert vous avez
grandi dans le new jersey vous avez
attrapé le virus de la musique avec
votre père qui était un boxeur pro mais
qui était aussi un ami d'une légende le
fameux jazzman thelonious monk
il ya dans les fêtes et les news manque
qui était mon parrain en fait et malté
baisse également qui venait ou au
gymnase ou me faire s'entraîner malgré
toujours avait toujours floues et boxeur
lui-même donc mon père était son papa là
dessus on lui dit mais non 1
alors voilà en 1964 il ya quarante ans
vous fondez avec votre frère un groupe
qui s'appelle de jack jack 1 ce qui est
une contraction entre jazz et maniaque
je pense influencé par non un sillon ses
parts et le new ce manque
miles davis john coltrane et puis votre
musique évolue vers le rythm n blues et
vers le feng pourquoi être passé du jazz
blues non nous sommes devenus le groupe
qui accompagnait un groupe qui
s'appelait sortant l'avion alors on
apprenait des chansons des smoky noir
benson des gens comme ça hein
et alors la partie jazz suivait et le
r'n'b se sont fusionnés en quelque sorte
pour créer la soul un petit peu dans 69
alors vous avez eu un petit creux de
vague à la fin des années 70 mais ses
revenus en force
aujourd'hui vous êtes super star par
exemple dans la bande originale de pulp
fiction
il ya un morceau à vous qui est zhang
albou
votre répertoire et reprise samplé par
des gens comme meys comme culio comme
peuvent des dix comme will smith
aujourd'hui vous êtes de nouveau au
sommet ne retient pas très peu de temps
en fait
en fait on est rendu là c'est la
génération du hip hop mais on sent plaît
beaucoup de morceaux tellement de
morceaux et ça nous a ramené sur le
devant et avec ce nouvel album également
et u12 vous savez cela permet à coller
mais qu'elle reste dans tout les
artistes d'aujourd'hui ça permet de
rentrer mieux dans la musique de kool
and the gang
alors c'est vous qui avait découvert
dans vos studios du new-jersey vous avez
découvert les fugees c'est-à-dire lauryn
hill et white en région c'est vrai en
fait c'est plutôt mon frère les fugees
et quand c'était il y avait un groupe
qui s'appelle camille d'inde et un happy
hour sexy après la découvert savent même
temps votre face est celui qui fait les
enregistrements en studio c'est un peu
le le producteur de du groupe alors il
s'appelle calice il est il est musulman
votre frère et vous aussi la faire oui
je suis également musulmans est ce que
c'est vrai que vous êtes proche d'un
groupe aux états unis qui s'appelle
nationaux fils l'âme de farah khan non
ça c'était il ya longtemps quand même
c'était il ya longtemps mais c'est vrai
que c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert
l'islam vous savez qu'il a une très
mauvaise image ici louis farrakhan we
have a long way pourquoi ouais il ya une
image un peu d'intégristes un peu
antisémites et c'est en quelque sorte 3
qu'on peut le dire
c'est pour ça que vous avez quitté son
groupe n'avait slam choix que nous avons
simplement évoluer un petit peu
mais également sur le plan musical ouais
mieux après tout on s'intéressait
surtout à la musique quand même et moins
à la politique mon aspect religieux
après tout ce qui nous intéressait c'est
l'aspect musical n'est pas de trop de
politiques politique ce n'est pas bon
pour le monde est en train de tout vers
le bas
la musique vient de l'âme la musique est
en général très pur la musique d'autres
musiques va directement au coeur des
gens qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
politique
new light laurie l'aurais je voulais
leur pose une question je voudrais juste
savoir pour quelqu'un puisse bien
quelqu'un qui prendrait les missions en
cours comme ça ce que pourrait croire
que je fais partie du groupe
m
c'est à dire ce serait un peu le minable
je serai à l'olympia le 9 et 10 juillet
ce sera notre nouveau chanteur you and i
want to be in france
oui jusqu'à ce jour les filles toujours
call girls et white ra easy girl
ah ah
she's not easy cd team à poil quand même
fait des villas boas je ne suis pas une
fille difficile bien donc poulains de
gains je répète le scénario d'une
faillite était trop palmer 10 juillet à
l'olympia
[Musique]
je suis pas
c'est
[Musique]
bon vu l'âge mais là messieurs
[Applaudissements]
merci à 25 abonnements
là
à 2-1
et maintenant quatre bleus
direct
pièce de pierre
il veut
qui marin mais ce qui me ramène dridi
[Musique]
bonsoir me met très vite ça va très bien
vous connaissez guy a lepage
j'ai fait sa connaissance qui va qui va
en fait vous recevoir quand vous irez au
canada dans le tout le monde en parle
québécois comment on dit non tu moment
parlant québec mois par la page tu vas
payer cela au milieu mais
personnellement il m'a dit alors c'est
pour ardisson mais bon il faut pas le
croire si c'est vrai nom s'est pour une
raison encore plus conne que ça c'est
merci eric bibb et le sait que quand on
est un artiste et au québec il faut
s'inscrire à l'union les artistes et il
y avait déjà un guide parachute et
l'imitateur andré philippe gagnon
peut-être que vous connaissez il
s'appelle pas du tout envie philippe
s'appelle andré gagnon et il y avait un
pianiste qui s'appelle andré gagné par
céline sa place et d'une fusion il ya
deux
il pas près d'aller au québec tu veux
dire c'est mon gars bien
alors moi m hidi vous publié chez michel
lafon un livre qui s'appelle momo le
turbulent sous-titré de la voyoucratie à
la jet set vous êtes né en 1968 et dans
une rue populeuse de tunis
mais vous dites en parlant de cette rue
c'est ce qu'il ya derrière les cartes
postales les endroit maudit où les tours
opérators n'emmène pas les touristes
tout à fait même soukra vrai ouais c'est
le barbès montfermeil réunis en même
temps 1 4 million +1
il ya dans 1 30 mètre carré ou 40 mètres
carrés il ya toute une famille c'est à
dire la mère le père les enfants les
beaux-frères et belles-soeurs le machin
et tout le monde vit là dedans même
temps pour un cercle soir quand on quand
ils dorment ils savent pas où ils vont
dormir si c'est à côté de la cuisine à
côté des toilettes de la salle de bains
ya pas de règles il n'y a pas d'endroit
bien précis en même temps tout est dans
la même pièce effet qu'est ce que tu as
fait moi aussi ça tenait déjà non non
c'est pas taper je te fais chier
il m'a lancé un petit défi
chez chez ruquier il ya quelques années
un et on a on a rangé sa vitre et qu'on
va céder histoire de garçon quoi ce truc
à un moment donné quand même temps ah
bah je me suis refait ma tête moi la
cause de ça c'était quoi l'histoire
l'histoire elle est très simple c'est
que laurent a voulu lancer le défi et
puis et puis franck a voulu relever moi
je les relevés mais c'était quoi le défi
qui prône une droite ont deux secondes
j'ai gagné je les présente trois bien
alors je le moment que tu mets très
sympathique ça me vient du coeur je te
le dis comme ça me dit tout à l'heure
quand tu m'as dit bonjour c'était pas
très très gentil
non mais je mets pas ta gueule tout à
l'heure et là maintenant je sais pas je
m'ouvre à toi je te trouve à tu
trouveras mauvais week-end en même temps
que la bien donc vous naissez dans ce
quartier défavorisé c'est le moins qu'on
puisse en dire de tunis et votre père
meurt 40 jours avant votre naissance et
avant de mourir il avait dit si c'est un
garçon je veux qu'il aille en france
chez mon frère
ouais alors voilà votre mère dit à votre
oncle si tu veux mon fils il feu me
donner de l'argent
ce qui fait qu'en fait vous avez été
vendues ou des avoirs à savoir qu'avant
moi y avait quand même des frères et
soeurs et quinzaine oui voilà donc
apparemment
entre guillemets c'est peut-être pour
les villes et les faire manger moins
qu'elle a voulu essayer de toucher un
petit peu de sous mais moi en tant qu'
en tant qu'être humain quand j'apprends
ça je suis dégoûté quoi vous allez bien
vous a vendu vous dites comme un coq
comme comme un chiot comme un animal
comme un esclave en fait j'ai été vendu
à votre oncle c'est à dire que lui en
fait mon oncle qui est devenu mon père à
vous le faire le désir de son frère qui
était mon père ouais et puis il a tenu
son engagement dont qu'il a il a fallu
sa wii vous a recueilli la payer votre
mère et vous avez maintenant je sais pas
s'il a donné de l'argent ou s'il a
ramené des vêtements ou de la nourriture
ou je ne sais pas comment ça s'est passé
mais en tout cas je sais qu'on ne savait
pas quel prix vous avez été vendus en
fait aux dernières nouvelles je sais que
j'ai été vendus entre voilà alors vous
avez revu votre mère trois fois dans
votre vie
une fois vous avez 20 ans où il devait
me fait un numéro de veuves éplorées
elle vous raconte qu'elle a été obligée
de vous de vous abandonner et et vous en
faites vous dit pas question d'y montrer
de l'amour quoi après ce qu'elle avait
fait pour moi c'est un être humain mais
pour moi c'est une étrangère c'est à
dire que quand je la vois je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'avoir un lien de parenté
avec cette pâte sentiment maternel pour
elles ont tous les kits à fait voilà
c'est que j'ai pas voulu sauter dans les
bras je n'ai pas embrassé comme si
c'était un enfant qui a pas vu sa mère
depuis des années qui lui saute dessus
c'est une personne elle m'a dit bonjour
je vous dis bonjour mais j'ai pas eu le
sentiment de
un d'être le père le fils de cette femme
ouais mais en même temps c'était une
chance je vous le dit d'ailleurs qu'elle
vous vendre parce que si vous n'aviez
pas été vendus en fait le cas si vous
n'étiez pas venu en france à l'époque
vous dites je serai peut-être en train
de pousser une charrette en haillons
dans une rue de tunis
c'est vrai que c'était un mal pour un
bien mais mais d'un autre côté aussi
j'ai pas j'ai pas grandi avec mes frères
et soeurs jlm a connu la nuit familiales
j'ai pas connu les anniversaires entre
familles j'ai pas connu le les
embrouilles entre frères et soeurs j'ai
pas connu tout ça quoi c'est vrai que la
vie n'était pas très drôle si votre
oncle larbi en fait votre père adoptif
il est un petit peu contraint forcé de
vous prendre
rutile me subissez plus qu'autre chose
il n'avait pas le choix ils étaient
coincés par la promesse qu'elle avait
faite à mon père est d'ailleurs vous
n'êtes pas de place dans la maison vous
dormez dans le salon sur le canapé un
peu comme un invité quoi c'est à dire
que jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans
effectivement on habitait dans le 20ème
du côté de la porte de montreuil et
j'avais pas de chambres à moi je dormais
dans le salon jeu
j'attendais quand il y avait des invités
j'attendais qu'il parte pour pouvoir les
dormir ou alors je commence à dormir
dans leur chambre et après j'allais
dormir dans la salle à manger dire que
ni ni en france ni en tunisie je me suis
senti bien quelque part vous avez 11 ans
vous apprenez la vérité photos à l'appui
un cousin à vous qui s'appelle farid
vous dit en fait tes parents ne sont pas
tes parents ses serres on lui déjà lui
déjà il sait et s'est comporté comme un
ya même pas de mot pour le justifier
parce que ça a été une vengeance dire
que le lui et sa soeur sont venus en
france
ouais
mon père kleiza les a recueillis et un
moment donné il ya un problème familial
donc ils ont été virés élus pour se
venger de sa est venu me voir moi à
l'âge de 11 ans qui à la limite n'est
pas n'est pas obligé de comprendre les
histoires d'adultes entre le match en
afrique il aurait mieux valu attendre un
peu c'est vrai soit il avait fallu
attendre un petit peu soit ne pas le
dire du tout ouais ou soi que ce soit
eux c'est à dire mon père et ma mère qui
me l'a prennent eux-mêmes
je n'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir une
vengeance dire que moi j'étais au milieu
d'une entre guillemets une guerre
familiale c'est moi qui en a subi les
conséquences
un enfant de 11 ans quand on lui apprend
qu'il va sécher le cours d'anglais qui
est en train de jouer au flipper dans un
bar du 20e de la rue des pyrénées et
canins qui arrivent et qui lui dit il
faut que je te parle entre hommes
ta fille s'adopter je vous garantis que
c'est c'est mieux qu'une douche froide
comprends c'est on sait plus dans quel
parti donc dans quel côté on part claire
oui vous dit j'avais vécu entouré de
menteur je ne pouvais donc plus me fier
à personne
là vous perdez confiance dans l'humanité
toute entière dans la famille déjà déjà
et vous péter les plombs vous disjoncter
vous commencez les fugues vous en faites
une par mois à peu près à l'époque en
règle générale j'arrivais toujours un
petit peu me débrouiller à payer une
chambre d'hôtel avec avec un sandwich
merguez pour pouvoir
on est obligé de voler à 11 ans comment
veux tu qu'on fasse des vols
effectivement vous dit j'étais devenue
une véritable petite keira un caïd de
bac à sable
dites vous et puis à la maison c'est pas
beaucoup de tendresse un bon dj pas eu
un seul cas l'un d'eux toute mon enfance
c'est même pire que ça c'est à dire que
quand je traversais la rue avec ma mère
ou avec mon père il y en avait pas à qui
me tenait la main ouais c'est à dire que
j'avais même pas une personne qui me
caressait les cheveux ou vire
[Applaudissements]
il en a chié réfléchi quand on réfléchit
aux choses c'est à dire qu'il ya peu de
choses pour un enfant heureux et c'est
peu de choses là ne sont pas capables
donnez donnez donc c'est en amont donné
on sait plus sur quel pied danser on a
plus de n'a plus de repère quoi alors à
15 ans vous découvrez les filles les
cambriolages 17 ans alors là vous vous
retrouvez dans les commandos
parachutistes au liban à beyrouth suite
à un vol à main armée que vous aviez
même pas commis derrière voilà ça ça n'a
rien arrangé à la sortie de sa vous
entrez dans la voyoucratie vous commencé
à fréquenter des gangsters corses et
marseillais la bande de la brise de mer
après vous travaillez solo en votre
boulot c'est racketter les bars à filles
ça c'est votre spécialité dire que
comment vous faites via un bar à filles
vous allez voir le mec vous lui dites si
tu veux pas voir dans merde tu me files
du blé ou amelia montage en passons dans
le milieu de la nuit a toujours des
problèmes
donc il suffit de rentrer dans le
sillage du problème et ou d'envoyer
d'aidé des histoires à 1
j'avoue créer des histoires dans un bar
est ensuite vite au mec moi je peux tu
as rangé le co voilà mais déjà les trois
quarts du temps déjà on a pas besoin
d'envoyer parce qu'ils les font tout
seuls les histoires donc exit savoir
quels sont les problèmes du mec du
patron de bar ainsi les s'il aime la
drogue chelem les mecs si voilà vous
essayez si on essaye de lui envoyer ses
points faibles
voilà on essaye de lui envoyer son petit
péché mignon dans
dans le filet et puis les trois quarts
du temps et tombent dedans et puis voilà
quoi des timbres auxerre caen fait en
fait
en fait il faut le mettre à la faute toi
tu casses les doigts et lui payent
chacun se partagent le travail on va
dire comme ça ouais voilà vous appelez
momo le boxeur en milieu ou turbulent
époque où turbulent vous êtes même à un
moment soupçonnée de meurtre
ouais sur une fille que vous avez bien
car si et en fait non non en fait c'est
un flic qui l'avait tuée ouais qu'il
faisait son service militaire qui
voulait savoir ce que c'était tu es
l'oeuf les voilà il a tué donc
cathy une autre fille à l'étoile et un
chauffeur de taxi
ouais ouais et par contre j'étais le
suspect numéro un
la jeune basané j'étais à toi tu as tué
personne homos n'ont jamais goûté aux
délices quand même tu racontes tout ça
d'un bouquin c'est géraud magrin tout ça
j'ai jamais eu de sang qui a coulé sont
mes mains j'aime bien les gants pour ça
ouais toujours pensé non mais ça n'a
l'air de rien tu as menée sur son compte
merci à toi c moi qui régale donc vous
raconter la prison lors huit ans en
prison ya pas de gaulois ya pas de
français de souche comme on dit c'est
peu très très très très peu wec du 15
pas le legs du cese pas de mec de 8 kw à
un endroit moins de neuilly vous parlez
des matons c'est une phrase terrible
concernant les maths on vous dit
eux ils sont là pour la vie bah oui ils
ont signé à perpète
ouais en fait c'est vrai ils sont pas
affolés voit cantonnée voile soir les
surveillants du soir venir avec leur sac
à dos et leur duvet blanc et tout c'est
le fait de savoir que tous les jours et
doivent rentrer dans ce donc dans cet
établissement c'est que quelque part
et puis voilà à vous quittez le
banditisme à cause de votre fils sofiane
gras trophée grâce
qu'est ce que dit grâce au public bien
non c'est vrai c'est l'amour de ma vie
ce petit bonhomme fait des câlins voulu
caresser les cheveux tu aimais des
mandales quand même jamais jamais sa
tête sur mon épaule ou mon épaule chose
ma tête sur son épaule c'est tous les
jours depuis vous avez quand même
découvert le cinéma - papa pas avec des
grands grands rôles encore mais je
persiste
voilà vous avez quitté la boxe
77 combat 77 victoires vous avez
rencontré massimo gargia qui vous a
introduit dans la jet set
oui ça c'est une façon de parler 2010a
il dit qu'il veut pas être un petit
rigolo des bonnes femmes dans la jet set
qui sont je ne veux pas être le ôb
service ouais voilà c'est pas observé
sid et ouais et vous devenez un pipe all
way puis pour l'entrepris mais vous êtes
un peu people ouais j'ai fait qu'elle
est une soirée people mais j'ai fait
j'ai fait quelques soirées j'ai fait
quelques photos et j'ai fait aussi la
visite il ne reste plus qu'à devenir
blonde pour être considéré comme un bon
français
vous y pensez à devenir blanc patronne
ont visité un bad boy enfin annexes en
tous les cas ça vous énerve les stars
qui jouent les bad boys
bah oui bah oui ouais bah oui c'est ce
qui qui sont des histoires des cv avec
soi disant un passé au placard de
placards de machin qu'alors que même une
garde à vue il se met à pleurer
alors maintenant au moment où il vous
reste plus qu'à trouver une petite femme
ouais chercher là bas ont bien sûr qu'on
cherche maintenant on va pas trouver ça
tous les jours mais effectivement j'ai
envie de feu de fonder notre une vraie
famille avec avec une femme et d'autres
enfants ma réaction
en fait vous regretter d'avoir quitté
karine ah bah oui ça a été la plus
grosse connerie de ma vie c'est touchant
quand vous racontez ça c'était la plus
grosse et d'ailleurs je me suis excusé
dans livre et je m'en excuse encore là
effectivement j'ai fait j'étais un
[ __ ] vis-à-vis d'elle dans le karine
vous étiez bien avec elle un jour elle
va se reposer chez sa mère parce qu'on a
une fille qui vous appelle
on vous y allez vous la sauter on est en
cloque et elle vous dit si tu veux que
je garde le gosse il faut m'épouser
marais est en fait elle avait 72
de plus que vous et vous l'avez vous
l'avait épousé sa pas duré longtemps
après ah non ça c'est clair quand le mot
mais n'est vous étiez déjà séparé ouais
et karine elle est où là bas une époque
à travaille pour une grande marque de
de bijoux du côté de la place vendôme
voilà et des plans d'eau
et puis une fois qu'une fois que le
petit a été nez gelé revue et elle m'a
dit que c'était pas beau c'est une faune
pu se remettre ensemble parce que
justement par rapport au petit elle le
verra le verra voilà dire qu'elle était
il faut dire que karen était enceinte de
moi elle a fait une fausse couche donc
donc si vous voulez après il ya eu un
décalage de l'enfant que vous avez les
pas de caréner sadaf les chiens malades
mais bon je suis content d'avoir mon
petit souci mais on est content de voir
comme ça en tous les cas c'est gentil
merci
[Musique]
ce visuel la bombe
maintenant on va recevoir quelqu'un me
ramène dridi qui pourra faire peut-être
un film à partir de votre livre voici
thomas landman
[Musique]
bonsoir thomas landman donc on essaie
tout le monde ici un petit peu m hidi
mais revoir attendant votre tour laurent
baffie vous le connaissez alors guy a
lepage qui va faire comment s'appelle
l'émission pif les au québec
non mais vous connaissez marina
absolument et franck dubosc
vous êtes déjà produit des films où il
était dedans les deux n'ont pas encore
d'accord voilà en tous les cas vous
produisez double zéro qui marche bien
très bien
alors dites moi un peu ça fait combien
le premier jour je suis maintenant je
fais jamais ça fait combien 152 mille
spectateurs c'est bien aller et quand on
voit ça le premier jour ça nous amène à
combien à la fin de l'exploitation
autour des 3 millions d'entrées
non mais c'est bien je suis ravi mazel
tov
quand en même temps thomas c'est un film
qui vaut cher maintenant c'est une
parodie de james bond donc c'est vrai
que c'est difficile de faire ça avec peu
d'argent
ouais c'est très bd comme vous êtes fan
de bd voix
c'est un truc quand vous étiez petit
votre mère vous interdisez de regarder
la télévision dont vous êtes jetés sur
des bd et vous avez attrapé le virus de
la bd en fait un doux astérix double ou
bridoux eric et ramzy qui sont des vrais
héros de bd en fait a lancé ce qu'on va
faire
vous avez regardé votre caméra vous à
dire magnéto serge et on va revoir un
bout de double zéro avec eric et ramzy
magnéto serge la division action
constitue la fine fleur de l'armée
française ici c'est du et pourquoi c'est
dur parce que c'est la condition du
succès question pourquoi n'y a pas de
portes hier lorsque ça ne sert à rien
pour l'exercice que vous allez faire le
cas c'est pourquoi ils vous sont
grandement utile pour l'exercice que
vous allez faire
[Musique]
mais c'est toi tu te mets vitesse de ce
parent et des résidents double zéro
produit par thomas langmann
vous êtes un homme heureux très heureux
alors il ya dix ans vous avez créé votre
boîte de prod qui s'appelle la petite
reine en mémoire de rennes production
qui est la boîte de votre père claude
berri on va faire nous aussi un hommage
à claude berri par dessus et il s'en
allait vers l'été dans notre petit matin
alors thomas est ce que sur dix ans vous
êtes gagnants ou perdants
je commence à être gagnant mais c'est
pas c'est pas forcément le principal jeu
je trouve que je suis gagnant depuis pas
mal de temps parce que je fais vraiment
ce que j'aime et je le en fait je fais
les films selon mes convictions et mes
goûts et mes désirs et j'ai la chance
pour le moment 2 jusqu'ici tout va bien
jusqu'ici tout va regarder alors dans
les succès il ya astérix et obélix
contre césar
là vous avez convaincu les ayants droits
d'astérix
vous avez convaincu depardieu et
claviers et puis après je vais parler à
votre père et ça a marché
tout le monde était content il ya
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre qui
a fait 14 millions d'entrées le boulet 3
millions d'entrées celui-là je les fais
tout seul et là je vous dire la vérité
honnêtement on est entre nous là je peux
vous le dire quand j'ai vu le film je
pensais pas que ça ferait trois millions
oui donc je pourrais pas être à votre
place
mais on sait jamais avant de démarrer
c'est beaucoup 3 millions c'est oui
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
il ya un échec mais peut-être doute mais
suis con connaissent et blueberry le jan
kounen vous était combien avec sa robe
long terme mille cent mille huit cent
mille 1 mais pour moi ce n'est pas un
échec
enfin c'est un échec économiquement
c'est certain mais ça fait c'est un film
dans suis fier avec c'est un film
intéressant c'est le côté ce que j'avais
dit à l'époque ccc l'abstraction sur
l'écran quoi c'est assez rigolo mais bon
c'est pas très publique
peut-être que dans dix ans on le
regardera différement alors vous
préparer le retour de fantômas avec jean
reno et josé garcia mesrine avec vincent
cassel benoît magimel
ludivine sagnier gérard lanvin et
monsieur alain delon à 30 ans franck
j'ai dit que j'admirais tout à l'heure
alors votre père comme vous à commencer
par être acteur pourquoi vous vous avez
arrêté d'être acteur parce que vous avez
été quand même nominé trois fois aux
césar c'est pas mal
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai arrêté de faire
acteur peut-être parce que j'avais
besoin de me lever tous les matins
d'être de travail et de réussir les
choses un petit peu par moi même et
j'avais l'impression que c'était
vraiment trop dépendre du désir des
autres donc je suis pas contre refaire
acteurs mais c'est pas un métier
enfin pour moi ça n'était pas ou alors
il faut effectivement avoir une carrière
j'ai envie de te dire un rôle écoute
c'est délicat de se donner des rôles
parce que si en fait c'est le metteur en
scène jean gérard paye quand même cher
mais je me paye bien comment est né ce
projet comment est née lequel tu penses
une question là
au voleur de balanda
et
si tu es sur un écran plat de chez vous
[Musique]
et maintenant aussi
quand j'ai dit ça
m
nous cherchons aussi à quatre canards
[Musique]
alors vous êtes responsable de la page
people dans paris match et que sa
demande de livrer ce soir d'être ici
pour un livre qui s'appelle meurtre dans
la jet set qui est publié chez michel
lafon et qui raconte sept meurtres dans
la jet set
alors il y en a un qui est passionnant
c'est celui de patricia gucci la femme
de monsieur gucci le fameux couturier
italien donc n77 femme son mari l'avait
quittée
monsieur gucci et elle a répété partout
que allait le tuer
et un jour il a été tué évidemment celui
tombé dessus
et oui 29 ans de prison c'est beaucoup
elle sortira trois ans ouais non parce
que on a navigué 80 encore oui ça va
quand on est riche
non alors est la vote
elle a pris 29 ans de prison
effectivement elle a obtenu une révision
de son procès parce qu'en fait tu as une
deuxième piste beaucoup plus
intéressante est une piste mafieuse 20
voilà parce que mauricio aurait flirté
allègrement avec la mafia est premier de
l'argent pour des casinos et au dernier
moment il se serait rétractée et en fait
comme pas triste et a répété après en
deux ans je vais tuer mourir je vais
tuer marie jo je peux plus supporter et
vas y poser la plante je peux plus
supporter à ce moment là le créneau
était parfum le meurtre parfait le
chapeau énorme
alors s'il est dit dans votre bouquin
que le chauffeur dit au moment du procès
le véritable assassin n'est pas dans
cette salle
mais si je parle je suis mort ce qui
ouvre effectivement la voie à des
suppositions sur une piste mafieuses oui
en revanche la voyante qui était
toujours avec elle qui a dû être
apparemment soudoyés par la mafia a dit
elle affirmé au procès qu elle lui avait
demandé de trouver un tueur le chauffard
donc
ninon et malheureusement le témoignage
de la voyante a été accablant est ce
qu'elle a dit madame gucci m'a demandé
de trouver le tueur mais voilà en
révision du procès une autre histoire
c'est l'histoire de gianni versace qui a
été tué à miami alors à priori vu que le
meurtre a eu lieu en plein jour on pense
que c'est un psychopathe un psycho
killer mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
rumeurs c'est ce que vous dites en te
regardant votre bouquin des rumeurs
comme quoi
versace aurait servi à blanchir l'argent
de la mafia
il n'est pas interdit de penser dites
vous que ce meurtre est lié à une piste
mafieuse aussi non ça c'est vraiment une
deuxième piste c mais apparemment c'est
moins clair parce que ce garçon qui a
tué était quand même un serial killer
ça faisait c'est un homosexuel l'idée
d'un coup s'est aperçu qu'il avait le
sida et qui a décrété et l'a fait une
espèce de mortelle randonnée il a
flingué tous les mecs un riche dont il
avait été l'amant 1 pour se venger
l'entourage a toujours dit qu'il ne
reconnaissait pas mais beaucoup de gens
en revanche on dit oui ils se
connaissaient et s'étaient rencontrés il
avait terminé voilà mars ou dans la jet
set alors il ya aussi sophie toscan du
plantier dont on ne sait pas s'ils
étaient réellement tué par son voisin
d'affaires est toujours pendante à n'y a
pas de wii alors moi j'ai parlé une deux
fois à l'assassin parce que c'est enfin
l'assassin présumé jésus nation
attention l'assassin présumé
parce que c'est moi j'ai enquêté sur
paris donc plutôt sur sophie et ses
appareils j'ai une amie qui s'appelle
caroline mon geste qui a enquêté en
irlande et en irlande elle est restée un
mois et elle voyait pratiquement tous
les jours b les uns c'était très très
étrange et rapport est belle et lui
avait dit si je peux pas de joindre
donne moi quelqu'un que je peux joindre
elle a donné mon portable donc j'ai deux
fois bel et au téléphone qui a une voix
magnifique plein de charme il est beau
mec
enfin maintenant il est un peu détruit
après toute cette affaire mais il était
plutôt beau beau mec et
mois d'après ce que j'ai mon enquête sur
sophie il aurait pu il aurait pu la
séduire à trois situations
ah oui 3 6 pts voilà avait parlé de la
comtesse augusta la femme s'améliorait
tac extraordinaire c'est fabricant
d'hélicoptère qui qui qui fait la fête
avec son mari un jour ils se cassent ils
la laissent
et on retrouve son corps à 400 km de la
terre qu'elle tombe à portofino
on la retrouve au cap bénat ce qui veut
dire qu'elle a sans doute été assassiné
elle a été assassiné mais là c'est très
très compliqué l'histoire parce qu'il ya
les grosses histoires de fric avec craxi
et avait pas mal blanchi d'argent est la
date d'ailleurs fait de la prison pour
ça mais en même temps il y avait
plusieurs elle avait un amant gigolo
elle avait un ex amant
qui était pas là il peut pas être le
meurtrier n'était pas là il l'a démontré
le mystère reste entier pour l'instant
il n'y a pas deux sur cette affaire et
en a quatre on n'a pas de d'assassins
vous raconter la fameuse histoire de
barbara colle aussi qu'on a retrouvée
morte un matin près de la maison de
johnny hallyday à saint tropez il faut
dire quand même très jeune il n'était
pas là à ce moment là on pense qu'elle a
été victime d'une overdose sur un bateau
et que que les gens l'ont déposé là pour
pour s'en débarrasser celle ci n'est
toujours en même temps en ayant essayé
en ayant essayé de la sauver et lui ont
fait un massage cardiaque qui lui a
enfoncé dans la restauration
donc ils ont dû voir ça espagne qui
panique elle a déposé
malencontreusement non loin de la dorada
voilà edmond safra au 6e ce banquier qui
a brûlé un sérieux ennui s'excuser
incessants gardes du corps qui pour
montrer qui est un mec vachement bien
allume un feu en disant regardez je peux
l'éteindre
en fait il n'a pas su les timbres est
l'hôte est mort brûlé enfin non et
surtout ce qui était étonnant c'est
qu'elle ment safra qui avait dénoncé la
mafia russe tu un billard et était
évidemment avait très peur donc il
s'était fait reconstruire une sorte de
bouquins mais vraiment effrayant c'est à
dire que tout était blindée on pouvait
pas rentrer n'est rien il a été victime
de son bunker
ils ont pu rentrer non plus n'ont pas pu
rentrer dans l'est
il est mort c'est pour toi c'est bien il
ya des histoires je dois dire que y'a
quelqu'un
oui quelle idée de film là un beau crime
bien flamboyant
ça s'appelle meurtre dans la jet set
agathe godard c'est publié chez michel
lafon
non
jean
on l a fait
mais com - malgré - mike comme moi
comment ça va ça va tu viens pour blind
test est à une carte de bons clients way
1 2 1 2 2 3 et 1 ch idée mayday mayday
alors c'est juste pour te remercier pour
la fois dernière mais dans la
précipitation et dans la véhémence et
dans la passion je me suis un peu laissé
emporter à savoir que j'ai défendue
osmose ensuite il m'a présenté comme
écrivain comme moteur à savoir près
bunker cent mille exemplaires aux
éditions du seuil
je revenais avec mon erre toujours chez
le même éditeur à 10 euros pour les plus
pauvres et pour lancer la lecture et
secundo avec beaucoup de véhémence
dépendance miles en freestyle en impro
aidant dans la rue tout le monde a du
reste est génial j'ai pas forcément vu
le film mais je vais acheter ton album
est donc j'aimerais rectifier le truc je
suis pas un rappeur je suis pas un
slameur je suis un écrivain et montner
je te le sort qu'est ce que tu sache de
quoi on parle il ya la version stickers
pour les mecs urbain comme je peux
l'être c'est-à-dire au stick c'est un
peu partout donc c'est moi quand vous
les voyez sur la capitale et il ya la
seconde version celle qu'on appelle
renoncer à savoir celle ci elle elle
débarque du seuil
voilà c'est moi c ra s'est agi des cetc
monnaire c'est mes tripes c'est c'est
mon second roman tu m'a offert
l'opportunité d'en parler et je voulais
trop mince et en même temps je voudrais
offrir tout ce qu'on pas l'opportunité
de lire tout ce qu'on pas l'opportunité
d'exister leur djia prenait le stylo
fait comme mohamed faites comme moi
balancez votre vibrations exister et
puis thierry sera là pour vous élancer
tiens
[Musique]
non
on passe au blind test
et aux platines j'accueille machine
philippe corti
bois
[Musique]
et puis est-ce que tu serais venu tout
seul ou quoi alors j'ai même fait
beaucoup mieux thierry oui nous sommes à
l'époque de la mondialisation
d'accord oui l'angleterre ouais
pas moi
c'est un monde entier on est diffusée
grâce à tv5 d'entre eux 27 pays qui
étaient en inde aussi en inde aussi un
bon beh oui qui te dit
allez
oui on est diffusé à la réunion
ah d'accord
[Applaudissements]
là
mme royal à corti royal
bonsoir mademoiselle je bizuth en voilà
un garçon qui ne vient jamais les mains
vides
c'est bien philippe lortie mangeant
magique
en utilisant les panaméens sur les
semences
la mort
[Musique]
c'est à toi ton carnet d'adressés
alors vous connaissez le principe du
blind test mes amis j'ai eu raison de
l'été lunettes marina parce que c'est le
moment pour écouter
oui c'est le moment important écoutons
nous absorbons je veux la terre prête
oui attention on peut donner un indice
si les gens trouvent que c'est un
spécialiste ali c'était un spécialité a
dirigé le chat bas il n'y ait pas de
fait c'est bien comme exemple à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas ça tombe bien la pression
quelqu'un souffre ici le pré va la cua
mais si quelqu'un au souffle la cua ah
oui il va là oui d'achat prévient
barzotti il est belge et non à la
mi-janvier pas ne faisons jamais
d'erreurs dans le clan jamais alors
attention laurent tu es prêt si on est
prêt moment l'émir philip wee guy lepage
qui va présenter une émission québec qui
va s'appeler on en parle
non
six mois
bien triste attention
recevant semble que man on man pour se
concentrent les enfants monsieur du buzz
attention philippe morceau numéro 1 je
me la pète
[Musique]
suite à la révélation
mais
[Musique]
jean
et je vais te dire un blind test de
corps filles c'est ce qu'ont les mecs
qui sont kamikazes quand ils sont fait
sauter pour l'islam ils ont droit à ça
voilà c'est vrai et c'est ce qu'elles
sont vierges
oui elles sont bien sûr attiré hawijah
rendre philippe alors numéro un donc
c'est laurent baffie qui marque le point
comme d'hab' à toi philippe numéro de
pluie
je
andrea bocelli
des civils
varutti non
03 bravo
m
blanc
l'eau
j'ai dit c'est quoi
c'est tout
non
alors ça fait le point pour l'équipe de
nioro ma fille c'est bien ça ils seront
ménagés au point à l'équipe de marina
foïs adéquat pour la vie de la batterie
mais c'est pas grave tu peux te
rattraper marina on a dit on au déjà
nous tous nos chanteurs italiens on est
associé à d'autres mais il est au fond
mon cerveau faut qu'ils reviennent voir
venir
attention philippe jamais je ne fais
plus rien c'est toto cutugno non
la date est arrêtée
à
on va y aller
et
rita arrey
et encore
marie ange
je crois je crois que c'est albano et
romina power
non
c'est la fille de cameron power qui
s'appelle romina power
absolument mais on n'avait pas d'idée de
chercher un non seulement on n'a pas dit
les duos non mais c'est connu ça oui
c'est connu on aurait trouvé en face à
eux mais on a le point va là puisque ça
a été trouvée la banane le point va là
elle ne l'a pas souffler à le point bas
du côté où ça a été trouvé ma ba oui oui
c'est le temps était bon d'accord c'est
déjà pas mal
c'est très bien et qui décide c'est
logique c'est moi qu'ils aient trouvé
mal chez moi je veux attention continue
avec sursis
[Musique]
or on
ça donne quoi
me tue
ça
cherchez pas si
si bas
c
[Musique]
serge à qui tu donnes le point à bafilo
à marina
la raison moi aussi je leur ai donné à
marina tu vois c'est marrant attention
philippe cau
dalian tac au tac
pourquoi
[Musique]
non
utah
bien toujours cutugno bien c'est comme
le 7 à la boule à un moment donné ils se
sentaient attention philippe
rené
[Musique]
mon soleil
3 3 c'est très bagarrer ce soir 3 3 pour
qui le rythment les primaires à jeter
dehors philippe il essaye de me le
demandent les titres et avec thomas
c'est un producteur mais il s'est réfusé
moi que c'est un produit sûr qu'on
attend d'eux poupaud ah non mais y en a
1 2 par le conte est actuaire
comme rida
et
[Applaudissements]
oui non
avi
non
[Applaudissements]
orlando exige le clip thierry scène
d'origine italienne carré bah oui bah
oui alors dalida est bien dirigé chanson
italienne s'est faite un américain alors
bas fillon devrait le demander les les
dates quand c'est comme ça berne où se
retrouvent trois mois c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas impossible
oui madame
c'est ce qu'a fait hier soir non j'adore
j'adore
tu peux
[Musique]
ça
j'adore ça là on n'a pas aussi ni la
solitudine que dia on continue philippe
corti madame le comté fort alamo nino
rota la ville et ouais
[Musique]
bravo au peuple de dieu qu'on peut
appeler à londres
belle fille impérial 6 combats fille
enfin pour l'équipe de baffie parce que
c'est vrai que momo et d un peu quand
même
oui c'est vrai 3 pour l'équipe de marina
foïs franck dubosc et notre ami thomas
langmann qui a plus de succès avec 2 0
rachid oui il a un prénom mais il n'a
rien trouvé
il faut qu'on soit mais n'a aucune
chance de gérer on rappela parce qu'il
n'ya pas frédéric françois je peux te
dire dans le blind test
rappelons la règle thierry rappelons la
règle ils peuvent jouer aussi ils
peuvent jouer ses droits sans dire des
trucs gentils mme sabban temps de le
dire attention corti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aj dressions bravo il est bon sur ce
coup là je dois dire si elles
connaissent
on a visionné mon père n'a pas les
prénoms la laci saskia on a les primes à
lamballe en saucière c'est ce qu'a
mélina mélina jeudi clémence nadia
d'accord merci je te regarder danser
après voilà d'accord on continue
aujourd'hui pas tension numéro
sur moi
ap
c'est
oui alors grâce à thomas langmann en est
à 6 6 pour l'équipe de laurent baffie 5
pour l'équipe de marina foïs alors on
continue
attention core tier one
bien sûr il faut s'arrêter c'est plus un
jeu c'est de l'humiliation je suis
désolé on sait que penser alors là les 6
voilà la fin du par équipes on est à 6 6
ce qui veut dire que l'équipe de laurent
l équipe de marina font match nul est un
petit peu que la france contre la
croatie jeudi dernier a fait jeudi
dernier un jury vient de moi ya ben
ouais
heureusement qu'on n'enregistre pas le
jeudi parce qu'on aurait raté en était
besoin son nom
heureusement que le candidat ait bon ça
c'est la force du bien
magie dans les règles font rien dire sur
les anglais un nom mais les anglais sont
très bien ils ont battu le record des
italiens pour reboucher le champagne on
a perdu à l'issue du par équipe en 1 6 6
et maintenant on passe au chacun pour sa
gueule
ok j'y vais merci attention n'y a plus
d'amis a plus d'équipé c'est clair donc
maintenant c'est chacun pour soi
corti à toi pour le bond coface cas
[Musique]
et non
la manade la pac le mec aveugle en
cellule avant
c'est un honneur
à bas la valeur
mais je lui reconnais que lui et moi je
connais pas du tout les gens donnent
d'ailleurs ce pc en devenant fan il est
désigné d'origine italienne sociale
je crois que le poids légal parce que
pagny pas ses impôts en italie donc que
ça attendez attendez catherine attendez
attendez
les habitables catherine barma dans
cette chanson we et voudrais que tu
passes la révélation un petit peu plus
longtemps katrina d'or qu'est ce que oui
mais moi je suis de me dire ses quatre
fils alors c'est la chef place et
l'achète
voilà c'est tout
[Musique]
le monde
oh mon dieu
il se sait
il ya donc le bon qu aulas a été
remporté par missenard achi et voilà
était même pas rêver au début on passe
le super banco c'est très très difficile
ans je pense que peut-être agathe godard
peut trouver parce que c'est notre
époque chérie c'est l'époque on écoutait
des trucs comme ça
vas-y même la radio terre noir et blanc
alors aumônier
ouais ouais bon mec
il a dit bobby solo in a dit
mais
pour
/
alors c'est un spécial rebeu parce que
le premier et le deuxième je me ramène
la discrimination en facial et les
rebeus qui viennent piquer les bons
coups des français je sais bien alors on
passe au méga bourgault madiot a c'est
hyper dur jusqu'à quand jusqu'en ultra
bon comme et façon tu trouveras pas
cherche pas c'est très très dur
corty
[Musique]
non
là
gardena
cardinal dans la marina
m
pourquoi citadine italienne il a dit que
claudia cardinale a dit sophia loren
elle est très belle mais j'adore le mec
il a quand même été à il a quand même
été au grand banditisme pendant des
années moi je sais pas mais encore ceux
qui six écoles bien donc c'est une
sophia loren et là je vois que ça fait
quand même deux pour mot à mot le
turbulent qui marque deux points momo le
boxeur qui marque deux points
et là on arrive maintenant à l'ultra
banco la personne qui trouve ça repart
avec toutes les filles repart et toutes
les filles non franchement je pense que
je vais jouer je vais me défoncer
bien alors attention tout le monde est
bien concentré c'est très très très
difficile moi j'ai du mal
agathe tu dois trouver sa merde elle
dort voilà non je dors pas laisser dire
attention aux fip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde
et non mes tubes dans les années 60
sexta
six ans plus tard
[Musique]
mais johnny rivers qui minait nova bus
qui sort la lune
google a tout bâti non mais
et
il
je viens comme jacques marsa le dimanche
jacques borde a été construit voilà là
laurent tu es un dieu vivant
merci dieu existe il est sur le plateau
ce soir cibox merci mon avis inverse
donc avis sud et chacun pour sa gueule
rachid un mot modeuses et les plus
difficiles été emportés par la magie
celle ultra méga banco voilà parce que
le monde est injuste
ah ben badis et maintenant on dit
maintenant pourquoi alors on pense à toi
de te dire pourquoi thierry parce que la
vie est injuste laurent un bal des
médias bongo tout ça que c'est pourri
c'est quand même calibre ce second co ou
franchement c'est chacun pour sa gueule
pourquoi c'est comme ça parce que la vie
est injuste laurent voyons la moins bien
fait que d'habitude un très bon et fait
de le faire après ça nous a bloqué jeudi
quand tu sais pas ça passe bien le
montage est en tout cas c'est un métier
ah oui j'étais tout près l'émission et
il ne reste plus qu'une et après c'est
la quille border sassetti c'est vrai que
c'était l'avant-dernière c'est la pire
pour la dernière c'est la dernière où l
avant dernière de cela plus la merde
elle était tout va bien d'ailleurs est
pour maintenant je trouve
l'avant dernière lors on était pas mal
et vous commencez l'année prochaine oui
non
oh
voilà c'était tout moubarak allait dans
ma vie
elsa zylberstein gros dans ma joie dans
un cinéma près de chez vous et aussi
pour thierry lhermitte d'american
magritte m chip hâlé thierry lhermitte
lorànt deutsch emile de kg est sorti le
16 juillet
victoria abril gauche toujours quel
jeanne labrune en évitant les gens bien
là où ça
si l'itc
le 28 juillet
et là
aussi la marraine de l'association
empannage africa michel mouillot tous
mouillés chez michel lafon comme du
beurre au secours j'ai 30 ans le
marie-anne chazel et franck dubosc
carbone
nathalie corré ça sort le 23 juin quand
ils bossent romantique en plus
à partir du 14 septembre au bataclan
jusqu'au 5 janvier
et à partir du 5 janvier en tournée dans
toute la france
franck dubosc saddam pax4 blog chez
hachette littératures alexandre ab
l'odyssée mais lequel c'est chez grasset
marina foïs
je me sens pas belle de bernard jeanjean
avec marina foïs et julien boisselier le
fameux julien boisselier
c'est le 4 août le 4 août valait à poil
marraine de la 20e édition de la fête du
cinéma
les 27 28
encore faut-il le dire joue ne gagne
l'album s'appelle the willows inn et le
single s'appelle fraîche et il
9 et 10 juillet à l'olympia hadj lakhdar
agathe godard meurtre dans la jet set
chez michel lafon ça sort le 1er juillet
voilà et quand tu montes monde
monsieur philippe genty voilà c'était
mon mental sa double zéro présent il
s'enroule atteint trois millions trois
millions d'entrées
ben tu vois ton bouquin mon heure rachid
djaïdani c'est au seuil de la messieurs
[Musique]
m
l'ondine la santé plein personnes salon
pour lady malaussanne savane où il fait
au del mas pinot grigio 10 d'uta parce
que
[Musique]
le muséum
des leaders tels que des pastels folk
adentro mais qui ça c'est tout
c'est
je connais toi n'ont pas
asko
omer
toute une histoire
hewson
mais là
monja
il faut
[Musique]
toi
départ
[Musique]
mieux
deminor
tu me donnes
m
de plus dix ans
grèce m a fait ma du gard
et comment
tous nient
peu importe à deauville
mais la casse
[Musique]
panneaux
allez